To Go.
The Joe rogan.net podcast one is this podcast called Joe Rogan experience.
That fucking website.
I'm just making shit up.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link that says fleshlight and put in
the code named Rogan,
you will save 15% off.
How about that Duncan Trussell not joking.
Wow.
What was that said?
I'll go up,
bitches.
Here we go.
The Joe Rogan Experience
[inaudible]
Ladies and gentlemen,
in this amazing moment in human history where not only was a prince wed,
but a couple days later and evil warlord was killed.
We are in the middle of an awesome movie.
That's what's going on.
We have a black president.
Princes are getting married in front of billions of people.
Everyone is happy for them and we killed the bad guy who was living in squalor
in Pakistan.
I'll tell you what,
I thought 1 million bucks would buy you a little bit more in Pakistan.
I thought for 1 million bucks you could own Pakistan.
I didn't know you would get that shit a whole house.
You're like,
this is a sound been lots of million dollar compound in Afghanistan.
Like what the fuck is it just like the most fertile heroin ground in the world?
I mean,
what the fuck is that?
Why is that house worth 1 million bucks?
It's probably,
I think it was built exactly to hide him.
So I think it was probably a large underground bunker type situation or it was,
had a lot of security and a lot of firewalls and stuff like that.
And maybe,
I don't know,
I was thinking that they're going to find him and fucking like woodland hills or
something like that.
[inaudible] you surprised that that they found him in Pakistan?
Yeah,
I was too.
It seems like you would have,
well,
the thing about that,
dude,
I think he's,
he's gotta be around his kind,
you know he's gotta be around militants only,
right?
You can't no,
no moderate people are going to be like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
That's Osama bin.
Ladin okay.
You know,
we're,
we're not,
we're not talking about Muhammad here.
We're not talking about another,
the guy that wrote the Quran,
we were talking about this guy who's probably the head of a gigantic terrorist
organization and he used to work for the CIA bin.
Ladin did,
Huh?
Putting one was working for the CIA.
You didn't know that?
No,
I didn't know that.
Who says that?
Everybody?
Yeah.
Oh wait,
no,
I think he did.
He had some kind of you in the mail room.
He had an agreement with a wet president was at the original Bush or something
like that.
I do remember that.
Barely remember some kind of like training you set up for some kind of training.
Well,
there's all sorts of allegations that the bottom line is that the United States,
the CIA,
the whatever the fuck you want to call them,
whatever under
what they did was they got all these people in Afghanistan to fight against the
Soviet Union and they help them.
They help the Mujahideen,
they help train them,
they help arm them.
And Osama bin Laden was a part of that.
And when the Soviet Union got out of Afghanistan and you know,
whatever happened overseas that shifted,
you know,
the Taliban and al Qaeda has interest in,
taking out the United States instead of taking out Russia instead of defending
themselves.
When,
when,
when shit got weird with Afghanistan,
that's when homeboy came into the picture and then he basically took over over
there supposedly who the fuck knows,
you know,
when you start talking about what the CIA did and you know,
and do what they're doing,
the conscious and the Sandinistas are you sure?
Because you know they've been lying about everything for so long.
Who the fuck knows if Osama bin Ladin Really Alex Jones thinks he's been dead
for nine years.
The nine years ago froze him and they're pulling him out right strategically in
line for when the new elections are setting up.
See what they did was they threw out this bogus birth certificate.
Have you seen the bogus birth certificate?
Oh,
you mean the pdf?
It's fake.
Yeah,
totally.
What people need to know.
I asked a thread about this last night and the general consensus among people
who understand Photoshop,
I put up a thread on the message board asking Photoshop Wizards,
please check this thing out and tell me what's up.
And there's a bunch of v.
What people don't know is a lot of people are claiming Osama bin or Natto sambal
up.
Isn't it weird that the president's name is right next to this evil evil
terrorists?
You think you would change his name?
I mean Kevin James Chen changed his name.
His name was Nick [inaudible].
Nick thing nip thing like with a k nothing wrong with that.
Just a complicated name to spell it.
He didn't want to go the Arnold Schwarzenegger take a chance route.
So like Jeff Ross wasn't Jeff Ross like Jeff Lip Schulz or something like that,
right and red band.
That red band.
Yeah.
There you go.
That red band guy,
he was like some Nazi name or something like that.
Well,
maybe,
maybe it would draw more attention to the fact like if Obama had changed his
name before running for president to Luther or,
well,
for poor white people,
he is such a nightmare because his nickname,
his middle name is Hussein.
Yeah.
It's like he couldn't be more fucked up.
His name,
his name couldn't be more threatening.
It is weird for dumb white people that must be so terrorizing,
you know,
just fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Anyway,
for people don't know,
supposedly he faked his birth certificate and what they did was people took the
image that the White House released online and they took the image and they ran
it through Photoshop or Adobe photo elements and they saw that there were many
layers to the photograph and the photograph wasn't just one flat photograph that
things had been added supposedly or that it looked like things had been cut and
paste,
but the general consensus among people who understand photoshops seems to be
that
when you scan something and you put it on in Adobe Photoshop,
it shows layers automatically.
OCR character recognition thing.
What it does is it tries to grab the,
the words then you know,
and puts them in layers for whatever reason.
I don't know why it does it.
Why was it annoying?
Yeah.
It might have a standardize it all the time.
It's annoying.
But you would think that people would ask about this before they would make all
these crazy claims that it's definitely fake because look,
it's probably fake anyway.
You know,
who's the sec with the fucking knows.
Who Cares?
It's,
it's anti American to care.
Okay.
What do you saying you're,
you should be able to be American because you somehow or another snuck in first.
You both got in.
Yeah.
Way in through the channels that we all agreed upon.
Did you really agree on those channels?
Because I didn't agree on them.
Right.
I,
I think we can do a lot better when deciding who gets to stay here and who
doesn't.
I know a lot of cool people that want to come here and can't write,
you know,
and there's cons here.
Plenty of them.
Um,
so who gives a fuck?
We're all immigrants.
The United States is based on the idea of immigration.
Come to someplace from someone that sucks and let's make this place better.
That's the whole thing.
That is when the United States is so when people start fucking tripping about,
he wasn't really born here like you,
you have to be shit out on the right patch of dirt to make you eligible to run
it.
That is the stupidest thing I've ever heard.
Both regardless whether or not you think it's stupid.
It is the law.
It is the constitution.
It is by our founding fathers.
They had the great wisdom when setting up this nation.
Great Wisdom.
They were dumb as fuck.
And they had wooden teeth.
Okay.
And slaves and they were fucking their slaves.
Were they really?
Oh yeah.
Tell Thomas Jefferson was fucking a slave.
That's,
yeah,
like it wasn't just like they were just,
you know,
happen to have slaves because that's what some people say that,
back then it was a,
that was normal and they were just doing what was normal and they didn't like
it.
But,
um,
what about fucking your slave?
Well do you think that people own like Mcdonald's,
a lot of them will fuck their employees?
Sure.
Isn't that Kinda the same thing?
Yeah.
Have you got someone working for you at Mcdonald's?
They're doing a full time shift at Mcdonald's.
They can't go anywhere.
I mean,
there are fucking slaves.
I might as well before slaves.
Mcdonald's is a chain and slaves are in chains.
That's fucking difference.
I mean,
no it's not.
It's certainly not as painful.
Donald's and being like having a manacle on and the door opens in some fucking
horny guy in a wig comes in.
I
think what they,
yeah,
absolutely.
But I think what they realized about slavery,
the reason why people were willing to let slavery go since it was,
you know,
it's so,
it's such a fucking horrendous idea.
And people were willing to impose themselves so much on other people that they
literally owned that person.
Yeah.
But I think eventually they realize you don't have to own them.
Just get them addicted to things.
Right.
Get them addicted to working.
Get them addicted to things.
Don't you need a new car?
Look at the shiny car,
new car,
but that kind of $40,000 and I only make $40,000 in a year.
Listen,
we've got financing,
we've got 0% down.
You don't have to pay a single payment for three months by then.
You'll be up on your feet.
Yeah,
finance that she know this fucking moron lives in an apartment.
You can't afford the car you can't afford,
and he's a slave.
He doesn't know he was a slave,
but he's a slave.
If you go anywhere and fuck off,
they will literally take away your ability to buy things and or throw you in
jail,
which is way worse than being a slave.
They're going to throw you in a cell with a bunch of guys want to beat you and
rape you.
Pay Your bills,
bitch.
You're a fucking slave.
Yeah,
it's true.
There is a version of that.
I mean,
there's no doubt that the thing is playing on a loop in the background.
You hear it?
No.
Do you guys hear it when we're talking?
No,
I don't ever hear it at all anymore.
I heard dramas where I was talking.
I was like,
what the fuck?
One of them microphone stands probably are is really,
yeah.
One of the things,
oh sorry,
sorry ladies.
Gentlemen,
my ultra tuned in hearing.
But here's the difference cause I've thought about this before,
which is the idea of uh,
that,
you know,
if you're working 40 hours a week,
uh,
that's its own form of slavery.
Um,
well the whole idea of something to trick you into doing that,
it's okay.
It's voluntary is instead of capture you,
you know,
it's,
it's voluntary slavery instead of in both types of,
it's mental,
it's a mental slavery.
I mean it isn't,
it isn't.
I mean it is freewill and it is a society that's open and you can work there and
save up your money and move on to a better gig.
You know,
and it's just a Gig.
you can take it until they figure out how to make robots that can do your job.
That's really what it's there for.
But you know,
people will argue that it's slavery.
When you see bunch of people that are super,
super rich and then they have super poor people that work for me.
Fucking don't do.
Yeah.
The difference that totally differences the freewill though.
You know what I mean?
That's like a huge part.
I mean,
I'm not saying that Mcdonald's or slavery,
they kind of are a little,
you know,
if you,
if you've got someone working all week for you and you pay him 500 bucks,
wow.
Could you imagine?
And that's like you got to get taxed to write the tax you.
So how much do you get?
Like three 53 50 for the week?
For the week.
So you got to live with a bunch of other people.
There's no way you can afford and you don't have time afterwards to go to
school.
When you get off work,
you're fucking exhausted,
man.
What are you going to do?
You've been working behind a fry later hating life for eight hours.
You know,
the odds are you're not gonna put up,
put forth your best effort going to college anyway.
You're going to kind of half ass it.
I,
you know,
like whenever I've been doing more than one thing at the same time,
I never do as well.
Right.
You know,
it's like why fighters can't have full time jobs and comics.
She cannot fulltime jobs either.
If you have a full time job,
it's fucking,
it's hard for you to write,
man.
It's hard to really get it and get in the sets that you need to get in.
You need writing,
you know,
three,
four,
five a week if you can,
you know,
at least,
right.
When you're writing new material,
it's hard to do that if you have kids.
It's hard to do that if you're married.
It's hard to do that if you work as hard as it.
That's once you're a part
of a system,
very difficult to change your life.
Yeah.
It's like we have so much momentum getting honest behind us,
rather that when we get on a path,
whatever it is,
be a doctor,
you know,
be,
be a fucking whatever the fuck you want to be at.
Be a mechanic.
Once you're on that path and you're moving and you're like,
shit,
I don't like this path.
This path sucks.
Fuck.
That's hard to change,
man.
It is so hard to switch gears and change careers.
We'll have,
it might be one of the hardest things a person could do.
The reason that hallucinogens became illegal is because one of the biggest pro
part proponents of hallucinogens,
Timothy leary was taking LSD and was saying,
tune in,
turn on,
drop out.
His advice to these people that you're talking about was completely drop out of
society.
This game that you're playing or you think you've got to go to work and have a
family,
it's just a game.
It doesn't exist.
It's not a real thing.
It's time for everyone to stop playing that game and let back game die.
That was the whole point.
Dropping out of society or ejecting completely every aspect of the society
you're in and just dropping out,
going into a commune or going into San Francisco and starting the summer of love
and wearing beads and dancing.
The problem is all those communes stories all end up with kids getting raped.
You know,
I mean,
I'm sure some of them don't,
but I have friends that grew up on communes.
I have a few of them and every one of them there was child abuse.
Okay,
well the the,
yeah.
Comments.
Failure.
Notorious.
Yeah.
Fail.
And they usually don't,
they,
they go up in flames literally quite often.
Like shit goes weird,
but it's like the,
the idea that we are living the best way that we can as a society.
Like this is the best we could do.
This is it.
This is the ultimate example.
I don't know.
These are the people who are afraid of love,
the idea of communes.
And you know,
I said that,
you know,
a,
a new,
uh,
a bunch of kids that had grown up in communes from the fucked up shit had
happened to him.
It doesn't mean that all of them do.
You know,
if you grew up in a commune and it was awesome for you,
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not negating your experience or learn or saying I know any better.
But what is it about communes that are so scary to people when you hear about
people branching off and going out and doing their own thing?
Like the,
the Waco Davidian thing?
Yeah.
When you heard about that,
the cult,
like when you hear about a commune or cult or anything that's like really
alternative to the standard model,
things get really weird.
What is that?
Why is that weird you out so much?
Well,
I mean,
you're talking about a lifetime of living in a certain way like that,
right?
But why do we care?
What other,
if other people want to do it,
is it because we're nervous or they're gonna attack us?
They're not going to be on our team.
What is it?
You're always scared of groups.
You know when you see a person across the street,
you don't think anything of it,
but you see a five of those people all in a circle.
You're like,
what the fuck's going on over there?
It's just,
it's just human interest.
Like something's going on there.
What are they up to?
What are they doing then?
It's mostly men.
Do you worry about groups of women?
A fuckup five women,
Bro.
I'll tell you what,
once hit one of those pitches,
the rest of them are just going to start running.
Yeah,
I guess.
But five dudes can kill you.
Yeah.
Five days can beat you to death,
you know.
[inaudible] you gotta be real careful with dudes much more than with women.
I mean with some woman you got to worry about him.
Yeah.
You know,
but obviously what is it about the big groups though that we worry,
we worry,
you know,
the government and I mean if you want to really kind of trip out how they handle
that Waco thing,
watch a,
there's a documentary called rules.
Yeah.
Rules of engagement.
And it's really interesting where it's just shows really clearly that they
murdered all those people.
Yeah.
And they drove over them.
Remember the ATF,
like drove their shit over the burnt down
breakage.
Yeah.
They left the house is on fire and drove over the houses with tanks.
It's really barbaric.
I mean,
it was just savage and it was,
you know,
this is how they had been operating for the longest time.
But the age of VCRs is fairly recent,
as is the age of the Internet is today.
You know,
we don't realize that there's a mentality of a bunch of people that were in
charge many decades before VCRs and the ability to show video to almost anybody
at any time.
You know,
that when VCRs came along,
all of a sudden you can watch something again,
you know,
and you can,
you could go what's going on here and what's happening there.
Whereas before they basically picked and choosed what they broadcasted on
television.
Once you had the ability to record things and then tape started,
you know,
passing around and,
and then,
um,
you know,
in the,
the,
uh,
the case of Waco,
I think that was the early nineties,
right?
Wasn't it?
Yeah.
Was early nineties.
I think so.
Yeah.
So they had,
um,
they had all these fucking people living on this one compound with weapons and
the guy was banging all the wives.
That's how it always ends,
right?
The guys is always,
the guys always banged somebody.
Well,
yeah,
I turned,
it's sex gets in there that like sex worms his way in there.
If it's not already there and shit gets weird.
Wow.
What a,
what a fucking weird thing.
I mean,
he made him mean he was like a martyr or he like had this self fulfilling
prophecy.
Yeah.
He made himself out to be this Jesus character and that they would,
all the government would come to attack him and how glorious must have been for
him when the ATF was storming the compound in a gun fight was going on of
bullets.
We're going,
it's like they're coming from me.
Yeah.
I'm too powerful.
They're coming from me.
He must've been like that.
Right.
A crazy asshole.
I mean,
sure.
He didn't want to die,
but he must been.
But yeah.
But that,
to go back to the question,
it is a very strange thing that when these alternate society spring up in our
society,
they're usually,
um,
they usually go bad or they end up getting attacked.
There's a standoff.
It's very strange thing.
Our society does not tolerate alternative ways of living,
sprouting up inside of it.
We want everyone to be living the same way.
And anytime that stuff starts happening,
the,
uh,
the officials getting here,
oh yeah.
This tune in,
drop out.
No,
it's not.
No.
Oh yeah.
That's like,
that's scary.
That was scary.
You know what's this?
I'm reading this book called the Harvard Psychedelic Clo.
Oh,
that's the Timothy.
That's,
um,
uh,
what's his face?
The Unabomber was involved in that,
right?
I didn't know that.
I haven't gotten to that part.
Maybe it's a different thing,
but getting book gone.
So it's like,
um,
Timothy leary and Richard Alpert who turned into Raam.
Dot.
So I always talk about,
and,
um,
Andrew Weil,
the Vitamin Guy,
you know that guy,
that guy with the giant beer and he sells vitamin products?
Yeah.
Well,
like the fucking story there is that,
uh,
Timothy leary goes to Mexico.
Someone gives him mushrooms.
He's never eaten mushrooms.
He takes them,
has this insane experience.
He's a Harvard professor,
so he thinks,
oh,
we need to study this.
This is,
this could have huge implications as far as,
uh,
psychotherapy go,
there's a,
we could use this.
So he goes back to Harvard and starts Harvard silicide been project,
which is where they're giving siliciden to students and,
well,
they weren't supposed to be,
but they're experimenting with silicide been to induce mystical states of being
there,
going into prisons with mushrooms and giving the syllable actually synthetic
psilocybin.
They're giving that to the prisoners.
The prisoners are eating it with them.
Like they would take,
they would trip out on mushrooms,
are the prisoners to try to do therapy.
And so,
um,
Andrew Weil fucking goes into one of their meetings where the staff is meeting
about this and like right to kind of negative news story and Harvard about how
these professors have started a semi called and her giving psychedelics to their
students.
And this ended up in Timothy leary and Richard Alpert getting kicked out of
Harvard because like the Harvard newspaper,
and I,
I don't remember the name of it was,
is read by like the president and stuff.
And so they got kicked out of Harvard and they went down to Mexico or taking
mushrooms.
And,
um,
this woman who used to,
whose husband used to be in the CIA was hanging out with them and she told
Timothy leary,
everybody's totally cool with you guys doing this as long as you keep it quiet,
like don't be loud about this.
And then according to Timothy Leary,
she called him like a few days before Kennedy died and told him he's,
he's like,
he,
he's,
uh,
he's going to start talking about everything and I'm really worried about the
precedent.
And then like a few days later,
he got shot.
That's according to Timothy leary.
But,
so you're saying that President Kennedy was doing acid?
Well,
President Kennedy came from Harvard and yes,
according to this book,
uh,
this woman who dated Timothy leary supposedly went to this,
Mexican p to this retreat or the hotel in Mexico.
And,
and as I recall,
like,
um,
you know,
said that she wanted to get some LSD for someone who's too famous to talk about.
And,
uh,
that,
so that,
that's an underground legend is that sounds like a bitch already said too much
about a kidnap her and thrown in the basement.
So she told me who the fuck that was.
That's a useless bitch right there.
And that seems ridiculous.
The whole talk way too much.
Yeah.
That story sounds like something that someone makes up when they work at like a
resort,
you know,
it's not ridiculous.
Counters got a great story.
That's like some guy that does a lot of drugs and talks at dolphins are at that,
but the CIA was experimenting with Lsd.
Yeah.
Well that was what I was going to bring up when you said that.
I thought you were talking about Ted Kaczynski.
You know,
the CIA did a bunch of studies in 1962 out of Harvard and Ted Kaczynski
volunteered for these studies and they cooked his fucking brain.
Man.
They created the uni bomber.
It's very,
very likely they created him.
When he got out of there,
he was absolutely convinced that there was some sort of a war going on between
technology and US and that he had to stop all these people from making
technology.
So what he did was he got a cabin in the woods and Montane worked for like five
years as a professor just to save up the money,
maybe three years as a professor,
just to stay,
save up enough money to fund his trip.
And then he moved and just started this attack on all of these professors and
innovators and all these people that were involved in,
in technology.
But they come bombs,
they cooked him,
do crazy.
They cooked him at Harvard,
man.
And that's something that is very,
that's not very really well known man,
because people have heard of that story.
People have no idea about the history of Lsd at all.
It's,
well,
if you want to look online,
look up.
I'll,
um,
the CIA doses,
French town,
because there was a town in France where it's been by the freedom of Information
Act.
These papers had been released and they found out that they did LSD studies on
whole towns in France.
They would dose the whole fucking village and watch people commit suicide watch.
All kinds of crazy shit happened.
Excuse me.
Um,
so you know,
they'd been doing shit on soldiers had states and Britain.
There's,
there's videos of a British troops all dosed up on LSD.
Wandering around.
Yeah,
it's fucking weird.
Amazing.
And now it's 10 years they were doing at Harvard,
uh,
10 years before leary started doing the experiments themselves to do,
you know,
when I saw that,
it was hilarious.
Speaking of old Shit,
I watch flash Gordon on the plane,
on the plane home from Toronto,
the original dude,
they have these little,
you know,
you can pick a TV show or movie Flash Gordon episode one,
two.
And I don't know if there's more,
it is amazing how bad it is.
I don't know what year that was.
Do you know,
in the years that was,
now let me look it up real quick because it was incredible.
The,
the,
the special effects were awesome.
They were so bad that it looks like a show that's trying to fuck around.
It looks like a show that like maybe Tim and Eric would do or the guys from
south park if they really like,
yeah.
Did you see yourself in 1936 that's when it is.
Do you know how crazy is?
We're talking about 1936 and this is like pre world war two man.
So they've got this fucking ridiculous spaceship that is got sparklers like,
like 4th of July sparklers behind it and it's on a string and it's like swinging
on a string with the sparkler shooting behind it and the way it's operated,
the enzyme with what they thought a spaceship would be like is,
it's insane.
There's a guy in a seat,
he's just sitting in a seat and he's got like a periscope just like you would
have in a submarine because they had submarines,
Baghdad.
Dude,
there's no monitors.
There's no not there.
Did going through space and they don't even have monitors.
They never envisioned monitors.
So back then you were like buying every single second.
I'm like,
yeah,
that was so realists.
Dude.
It is awesome,
and I just looked up on IMD MDB.
Apparently there's a DVD set you can get.
I fully recommend a stone session.
Get stoned as fuck and watch flash Gordon.
It's going to be awesome,
but that's,
it's amazing.
It's amazing to think that that's even real,
that this was like this was a show or the movie rather,
where you know they were,
they were,
this was fucking legit.
People get fired up.
We're going to go see Flash Gordon.
He's going to beat that and beating the Lawrenceville Sga.
You
go in there and that's hilarious.
By their homemade coca cola.
I was watching old twilight zone.
Same thing.
Not as bad as that,
but twilight zone,
like the old school series,
they're mostly had to do with astronauts and you have photos like it was the
same always about space stuff.
It's so weird that people bought that back in the day.
I love the twilight.
I love watching old twilight towns.
Yeah,
there's,
you know what my favorite one is Burgess Meredith.
When is the last man on earth and as he is,
he's like in a bookstore.
So he gets all these books and he's still excited cause that's all he wanted to
do.
People just bother him.
He really just wanted to read books.
Yeah.
And so a nuclear bomb hits everybody's dead and he's got all the books in the
world to read,
but he breaks his glasses.
Uh,
I remember that one did so good.
That was awesome.
That was really the perfect show was the perfect show.
When is when that episode was Donald's like wow,
perfect show.
They did a twilight zone where a pool,
a pool hustler wanting to play the the dead guy.
And when he wins he goes to hell and he wins and he's guarding over the pool
table waiting for the next guy because he wasted his whole life playing pool.
That's his,
that's his suffering.
Those twilight tones are all so good.
How come there isn't a show like that now?
I try to do man,
every subjects we covered a billion times over to be completely and totally
original like that.
Like wow.
You're talking about,
you know,
millions and millions of shows.
It's fucking how much stuff has been made since 1936 and they buck Rogers or
Flash Gordon,
you remember amazing stories.
They tried to Redo kind of like that same format.
That was awesome.
I never saw that.
Amazing stories.
That's pretty good time.
It's like in the eighties I love those toilets on movies too.
But then the course that one with John Landis had that horrible accident with a
helicopter crash.
His crazy wife to kind of head off.
Yeah,
you're
capitated dude,
that it's fucked up.
Fuck movies with explosions and helicopters.
Keep that shit away from me.
The good news is they don't really have to do that anymore because now they have
CGI.
They just,
you know,
fake the whole thing.
They don't,
you know,
in 2012 nobody really jumped a car over a fucking canyon,
you know what I mean?
They just had,
the whole thing was fake.
So it's nice.
You don't really have to risk your life for some shitty moving men are fucking
crazy man,
dude.
Like the craziest,
I worked with those guys for years on fear factor on fear factor.
I work was stunt guys.
I knew a few guys from Jujitsu.
Um,
my friend will we train to John jogs a new couple other guys when there um,
but uh,
there are fucking animals.
All of them have like,
oh this is metal.
I got a fucking fake collar bone and you know,
I got 18 stitches in our 18 plates in this hand.
Have you seen the video of the,
of the window washer and lethal weapon that is washing the window and the car
basically it's a stunt that went wrong and a car went through the wrong windows.
So there's the two stunt guys and they're like washing this window because they
have the outtakes and you see them like all of a sudden brace themselves and one
guy like jumps trying to get out of the way and a card is,
goes through a window,
smacks one of them knocks and backwards into the a building he was finally,
he wasn't fine.
He had to go to the hospital for a couple of weeks.
I just met that guy.
Fucking crazy.
Is it in the video?
Can you see it in the video?
It's on the Internet.
Look up lethal weapon like stuntmen man accident,
but match it.
He was such a cool guy.
It's like stuntmen or,
or like a very specific type of person and it's like a job that sometimes passed
down through families and stuff.
It's like a,
you have to be really,
really crazy to do that.
You gotta be tough as fuck tough entails.
Tait Fletcher has been doing,
he's been doing like all the avenger movies.
Oh,
totally makes sense.
But they're super,
they're super careful.
They're super careful and they're like,
I'm there.
It's really interesting to see how it fits,
how fastidious they are.
But this guy was talking to him about the stunt and uh,
he just kept saying fire stunts are as safe as they could be.
There's nothing safer than a Firestone.
I'd set,
my kid's on fire.
He can say,
what the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That's a guy.
Might be a little too confident with himself.
I know.
I mean you,
I guess you have to be.
Cause if you're scared,
if you're scared during one of these stunts and you spend any energy on fear,
you're fucked.
You'll,
you'll get killed.
I couldn't hurt it.
That shit.
Fuck that.
Even the girl stunt,
I can med being a girl doing that.
The stunt women,
because it was a tough broads.
They're getting thrown out of the back of trucks.
The fall guy.
Come on.
Remember the fall guy,
Mr you remember Alf Alf's,
Joey Diaz gigs.
A stunt man now Joe,
you remember out with was alpha.
I was an alien.
We cats.
Really?
Yeah.
How did that get through?
Watched an episode of Alpha.
I kind of pride really from that or sure.
All current.
Yeah.
I remember it was a reference that hack comedians would do in the eighties or
the nineties rather max headroom.
How bad ass it before the time was that guy,
what was that all about?
He was like as a Hologram.
Hologram.
Who was he supposed to be?
She's supposed to be a computer or something and this is huge.
This big computer programmer.
He lived in the computer.
Yeah.
I don't remember.
Was He?
Oh,
see artificial intelligence.
That's what it was like how I used to watch that show.
The TV show.
I remember I was at fucking loved it back in the day.
It started off as at what?
A Pepsi commercial or something or,
and then it became a show.
Then became a TV show.
I saw that guy in some weird B movie one day or the guy that played that guy.
Huh?
It was weird.
I was like,
no,
no.
Your Max head room for,
I can't be some guy in some movie who's like a cop,
you know?
I think we've got a clue here.
I was like a bad cop movie.
It's a,
they really haven't brought him back for like to sell iPads or something.
You know?
Why don't you fucking make the pitch son do it.
Get that guy together.
You know,
today with the technology that we have today,
you actually could do that if you wanted to.
You could just film it on a green screen,
green screen of your own,
throw it through your laptop.
Super easy,
using super easy.
So,
so come going back to this flash Gordon thing,
man,
if you ever want to fucking,
you ever need proof of evolution for knuckleheads?
Just look at Flash Gordon.
Look at that from 1936 and look at us today in 2011 if you can't see that things
are changing and moving in a certain direction,
the complexity of the dialogue,
the simplicity of it in the Flash Gordon movie as compared to like what you were
having in this conversation right here.
We're two totally different human beings.
I mean these people were,
I don't know if they were incredibly naive or if just the,
if it was that the cinema was so new and naive that it could be stupid and fake
because Noah,
everyone sort of accepted it.
You know what I mean?
Like when they saw those old King Kong movies,
like I love the first guy.
I love all the King Kong movies,
but the first one was pretty bad ass,
but it's so fake looking.
It's so bad if you go and watch it now,
you're like,
Whoa,
what?
But back then they knew,
you know,
the knew it was gonna.
It was good for them.
I was like,
wow,
I can't believe that that's the monster.
You know?
They didn't have anything to compare it to.
They knew it didn't look real,
but they were still impressed that pertain Kong's a hell of a monster.
What a great movie.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
totally.
It's like,
you know,
it's like three d look how much three ds evolve.
But when you first went to,
when I went to see jaws three d when it came out and where those red and blue
glasses,
I was like,
oh my God,
Holy Shit,
this is incredible.
Like they,
there was one scene where a needle came out of the screen and it was just like,
whoa,
that's crazy.
But,
so I was just happy.
I didn't care about,
I didn't know that there could be better three,
three d than that.
I was just blown away.
So it must've been the same thing.
It's kind of weird how it took a long time for three d made a comeback.
I don't really think I really made a come back either.
Well Dude Avatar in my opinion,
the Admin of combat and when I saw it in imax three d that's like an experienced
man.
Yeah.
I had a smile on my face,
that whole movie.
And when I heard all these people
that were like,
Oh that movie's so the plot was very transparent and like,
oh my God,
shut up.
Shut up.
Stupid.
How could you not enjoy that?
Oh you're telling me the big blue aliens aren't real.
Whoa,
get outta here.
No.
Are People like after Avatar people reporting depression like,
but yeah,
cause they are,
depression was a real thing.
Yeah.
It's a fucking,
there was no color and after Avatar,
I wonder how it's recognized.
I wonder if like psychologists are behind it.
You,
well you have avatar depression.
It sounds like you've got a bad case of Avatar to press that's not outside the
realm of possibility.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
Well I know the depression that comes from um,
playing a really awesome video game.
And then going out into the world,
you know what I mean?
Like there is,
we're driving here and we'd go,
we go by this mountain of rocks and he looks out the window and he goes,
oh,
that's like what?
What is that Chris Mar?
Oh,
good word for word work,
right?
I'm like,
I don't even know what that means.
You have a fantasy environment.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Well,
I just got this Imac.
I just got this like giant Imac,
like the biggest monitor I've ever had.
So I was like,
well,
aren't those awesome?
I've got to see what words suck.
Mine died today.
Yeah,
but it's probably just a hard drive and no hope not.
Oh God.
I've got to back your shit up,
dude.
You got knocked up there.
Don't have things back.
Not that,
not that computer,
because I use that computer just for audio,
like you know for podcast and audio and you can slap a fucking one terabyte
drive on it.
14 Times.
Share Bite,
full drives.
I just keep on running out of hard drive space.
Wow,
that's incredible.
Yeah.
Fucking sucks.
That shit needs to go away.
What happened to,
I remember when I worked at gateway computers,
I don't know if we talked about it as anyway he's telling him,
put him on his back.
It is awesome.
I know you were saying that your shit died but it is awesome.
And what were you gonna say about that?
I was going to say it's like a fucking window and do an alternate universe.
When you've got a really good video game and you're looking at it,
it's like these,
I think the word video games,
you got to go down the tube is man because you,
you,
someone hears,
you say,
I love to play video games.
They're like you fucking nerd.
But it's like it cause you know it's like,
but what it's turning into it's not really,
it's going to get to the point where it's not video games anymore where it's
something else.
Like I feel like it's like world of Warcraft,
starcraft,
all these like a portal.
What we're,
this is the very first surge of water and this virtual tsunami that's about to
come subjectively sweeping over everyone.
Because that thing you say about like maybe our neurology can't resist movies
cause it's so overpowering.
Yeah.
It's like,
I think that there's going to be some truth to that because these games are
missing a few components.
And this is,
this is what I think of when I'm stoned,
playing world of Warcraft.
If I could smell like,
if there was a sense of smell involved in this and also they've made that,
there was a sense of like,
yeah,
I mean it's,
they've made machines that do that.
I don't think I ever have to be a mind
thing.
It's a mind machine thing.
I think it's going to have to be,
so it's gonna be a little,
stimulate some part of your mind.
It's the mouse.
Yeah.
Like maybe you can wear some,
maybe everyone's going to have to shave their head.
Like real players.
If you,
you know,
you're going to have to do like a horizontal Mohawk thing.
Real plates.
I,
you know,
like this dude's legit,
he doesn't give a fuck,
goes out to the club,
but this big stripe shaved down his head and then you put this thing on skin to
skin on your head and it has precise,
like you line it up on the video game,
he'll show you how to line it up with the exact cortex,
exact portion of your brain.
And then it sends signals that show you like burning,
meet,
smell and show.
Yeah.
And then,
but then you know what else it does while you're,
and this is really weird,
while you're playing the game,
it erases your memory of your previous life.
So the moment that thing goes on,
you have no more past you or just the memories of the character in the game,
rushing through the game,
playing the game,
completely unaware of the fact that you used to exist as a person too.
And then you know what happens?
You're doing a podcast,
you're like,
oh fuck man,
my heart feels weird.
And you suddenly wake up and your futuristic apart and you're like,
aw man,
that game was awesome.
So right now we're playing a game.
Yeah.
Like yeah,
like that with a lot of people say this could be like some alien simulation,
you know that we're just an alien and involved in a really high powered,
super advanced bad as video game called planet experience.
The lives of billions of people all individually.
I wrote something once about maybe the life that we're living.
Maybe the reason why it seems so fake is cause it is fake and what we are in and
some sort of a reality simulation of the roaring twenties of the technological
age.
Like maybe we live in some time where everything is all scented candles and
perfectly lit white rooms and no one has a muscle car and no one's getting their
dick sucked.
And you know,
and maybe there's like a simulator that you can run where you run where it's
just chaos but chaos that's entertaining as fuck.
It's like every time you turn around there's some new thing.
Christina Aguilar fucking up the national anthem,
2 billion people tuning into the wedding.
There's constant shit going on to keep you entertained and you are,
you are in this biological ride canister.
Yeah.
And you're going through this thing,
you know,
you're in this year,
your portal to this ride is your skin and your flesh pops,
it pops through into this dimension and you know,
and it sounds like you're advocating fantasy.
It sounds like you're advocating,
well,
you know,
so you want to look at your life as if says if it's some sort of a simulation
and just live it as a simulation.
Well,
no,
I'm just saying,
yeah.
I'm saying yes,
I am sad.
Why not?
Right.
It's very empowering.
Yeah.
I think the first person ever heard suggests that was Mckenna.
I think Mckenna was talking about,
uh,
you,
how did he say he was?
And he was quoting someone else.
So I'm doing a third hand quote,
but he said you should view your life as
you say it,
as a conspiracy or as a view your life as it's as it's as if the world is run by
a select group of people and that group of people is you and your friends.
Yeah.
The,
your,
you're somehow or another secretly in charge with running the world and running
the university,
the most important things in the university shoe and your friends.
Cause it's the most empowering way to view the world.
Well,
yeah,
because what's that?
Yeah.
Cause what's the other side?
The other side of it is this kind of like pseudo empathy for like strangers that
you don't know.
Like so many people wander through their day just frothing with terror or
whatever they've seen on the news.
And so for them the world's awful,
but then they're real situation is usually pretty good.
Yeah.
You know,
like it's like a fucking,
uh,
Bill Hicks has that awesome joke about CNN,
CNN,
watch the news and then outside it's like beautiful and the grass is growing,
right?
So there's this mental pollution that comes pouring out of every information
device that we have and that like corrupts your mind and you begin to think
you're in a horror story when your real reality is one that's usually quite
pleasant.
This theme has been going back and forth with me over the last couple of weeks I
was talking about.
And even on stage in Canada that I don't think,
and I think it goes along with the same thing that we were talking about as far
as us not being able to process films and w w you know,
movies and that what I was saying with that was that movies for,
for those people who've never heard it before,
I think that human beings are set up to imitate their atmosphere and we're set
up to find the Alpha and follow him because he's the old leader and you know,
he's the guy with the broad sword that is the most nicks in it and,
and he's experienced things and you can learn from him.
And so we,
so we follow him that we don't,
we were set up to imitate our atmosphere,
but we don't know when our atmosphere is bullshit.
Those same signals.
All of a sudden we're getting them from a hundred foot screen and right.
And we're sitting there and Imac surround sound and the hero,
every time he comes on screen,
he says the exact right thing.
But he's got a fucking team of writers and they've been working on it for weeks
and there's music plays every time he's in the room and you get drawn into this
thing where it's,
it's incredibly influential,
like almost more so than real life.
Yeah,
and I don't think we're set up to,
to process that.
I think we're set up to process the natural world.
Well,
I mean that this is along the same lines.
Is that right?
I think when you look at the news and there's terrible things going on all of
the world,
I don't think we're set up to process the world.
We're set up to process or fucking neighborhood,
right?
The universe.
The world is a chaotic fucking place.
And the key is when some are socks gotta get the fuck out of there.
That's how people got to America in the first place.
That's why people crossed the Bering strait when they came over from Asia.
Every PR people,
we are nomadic for a reason.
It's because the world is spinning around a fucking nuclear explosion and
sometimes it gets a little too far away.
And when it does,
everything freezes to death.
Okay.
So you've got to move around.
You got
to keep moving.
And I think we are,
we supposed to be in a good spot and surround ourselves with a bunch of good
people,
but we can't be looking at the whole goddamn thing all at once.
The whole six to 7 billion people all over the world.
Yeah.
Everywhere you go,
you're going to see bombs going off and people getting shot and planes drop and
fucking missiles out of the sky into the wrong building.
And you know,
you're gonna see that everywhere because they're so fucking many of us.
You're not supposed to be monitoring the whole,
well,
I mean it's,
it messes up the paradigm people are enjoying.
And that paradigm is its own little virtual reality game.
It's like they,
you know,
people live in denial of death.
They live in denial of the impermanence of everything.
They live in denial of their,
of the fact that you will not be able to hold on to anything.
Ownership as a complete illusion.
You can't really own anything.
There's no such thing as it's countries,
but you can hold onto it for a little bit our countries because if you go over
there,
you've got to have a passport.
Yeah.
But those countries can lock you out.
Those aren't,
those countries are in.
These are what's happening is people are in forcing invisible thing.
Right.
But they are enforcing them.
Well,
yeah,
but that there's hearing me for example,
there's law take the law of gravity.
The law of gravity does not need police officers to make sure that the law of
gravity works.
If you jump off a cliff,
it's not like you land at the bottom here.
Okay.
And cops come and arrest you and say,
you just broke the law of gravity.
We're going to have to kill you.
The law of gravity kills you.
The human laws on the other hand,
these are laws that they aren't real except from the enforcement of human beings
and from things written down on paper.
But there they are.
It's not real in the sense of the law of gravity and is a society shifted
throughout time.
These laws have changed too.
So they're impermanent and they're always,
I mean,
God,
there used to be,
uh,
bathrooms for black people.
You know what I mean?
That was a real law.
That was a real thing.
And that,
that law is not real.
That law doesn't exist on the planet.
There's no underlying mechanism.
Uh,
we've seen it.
But it seems to me,
this is like a argument of semantics.
It's like what is the definition of the word law?
I see what you're saying.
But the reality is laws exist.
If you go to Turkey and you have heroin strapped to your back and they catch
you,
that put you in a cage.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
no,
I don't think it's,
there's social engineering.
The,
the,
the real question is,
is that social engineering,
is it valid?
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
Well,
no,
I think many,
many times the social engineering is not,
well,
that's what all the laws are.
Right.
And when you agree they're all social engineering yet don't do heroin because we
don't want heroin.
Users
don't,
well the idea would be I think that laws like good laws would be laws that were
a natural expression of a kind of a metaphysical function of the universe.
So
you say that man,
but then you've got to realize the nature of man,
man is a violent fucking crazy animal.
And if you want to allow the nature of man to express itself in,
in a,
in a truly unfettered way,
you're gonna have a lot of violence,
man.
Yeah,
it's called the United States.
I mean,
look at what's happening.
This is the nature of man being allowed to express itself in an unfettered way.
It's just being done from,
it's being done from a a on a massive global level.
I agree.
And I disagree because as individuals know,
as individuals,
most of the day is filled with very little violence in comparison to what life
would've been like 10,000 years ago,
life 10,000 years ago.
The,
by the time you got to be orange,
you are missing a hand or something.
So fucking aero holes in you if you made it through,
you know,
giant fucking machete mark in your head that you are experiencing violence
around every corner just to stay alive.
I think,
you know,
laws and all the things that are in place that a lot of people wouldn't agree
with.
You know,
even some drug smuggling laws.
I think you need some sort of regulation on these assholes that want to come in
here and sell poisonous shit that makes you addicted
to know the are a another way to look at it might be with your child.
You've got certain rules that you have with your kids where you have to tell
them not to go into the med medicine cabinet and eat these things because they
can't regulate themselves and they'll,
they'll die from it.
And those laws are obviously necessary in there.
They're good.
Right.
But what I'm saying is there's so many laws that aren't necessary.
Yeah.
There we're in agreement on that core profit to,
you know,
that its laws that are designed to yeah.
We are in agreement that it took to rake money in to,
you know,
the prison industrial complex.
It's,
it's,
these are the,
a lot of these laws,
oh,
help make a lot of people a lot of money.
And when you say prison industrial complex with a lot of people are not gonna
understand that statement.
So just tell people what the fuck that is.
Well the eye,
well basically you know,
running a prison as a business,
well don't know is that a huge percentage of the prisons in this country are
private.
Their own,
their companies and they profit.
They make money off of how many people are in prison.
I mean it's to even hear that and think that somehow somehow that got passed and
they allowed that.
And when we're talking about slavery earlier,
I mean how is that any different than owning people?
Yeah,
they fucked up before they became slaves,
but then once they fucked up,
they became slaves and you're making money off of them.
You make money off them being in there.
You try,
you charge more,
you know,
debate based on how many are in there.
I heard this statistic,
there are now more black people in prison than there were slaves.
Now I don't know if that's true or it's true.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I read that.
Yeah.
So I mean and,
and like how many of those people in prison are there for doing something really
awful?
Like what's the percentage of violent crimes versus nonviolent offenders?
And then cause like the people who are in there for like rape and beating people
and doing crazy shit,
of course they should be behind bars.
There needs to be some justice invoked.
Cause some people can't defend themselves obviously.
But people are in jail because they smoke some weed and their car is this,
this is not all prisons though,
right?
Cause I mean,
aren't they always saying that?
Prison's a care turning away people because as
you know,
they just don't have no,
but there's like county prisons and there's,
there's different prisons,
you know,
I don't know what percentage,
just not all prisons,
all of them are,
couldn't be.
But it's a huge number.
It's a huge number.
And they're making new ones all the time.
That's the key.
The fucking,
when the economy goes south,
man,
people start going to crime.
It's just how it goes.
I mean,
it's,
it's normal.
I don't know what the increase in prime has been since the economy went to shit,
but it's kind of be a couple of percent or something.
I mean,
it's just what happens and that to them,
that's,
that's numbers,
dollar,
dollar bills.
Y'all stuffed them in those cages and start raking in the cash.
It's just so weird to know that that's a real thing.
Well,
I mean it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's a form of vampirism.
You know,
you're basically like sucking people's life energies out of them,
converting it into money and then using that money to like buy nice things for
your beautiful wife.
I can't tell you how much I'm disappointed in Obama as a spokesman,
as a,
as a representative of us.
And you know,
not,
I don't know what's going on in the world.
I don't know exactly what happened with those.
Was Osama bin Ladin or any of this,
why we're bombing Pakistan?
Why we're involved in,
I don't know.
Who knows Michael for our own benefit.
How come this motherfucker,
a guy who came from a single mom,
how come he can't step up and figure out some way to get people to put funding
into horrible neighborhoods to try to make the system better,
to try to get more cops into those neighborhoods to try to get more teachers
into the schools that are more qualified to pay them more,
to set up community outreach programs for kids who don't have fathers and set up
like,
you know,
mentoring things and you know like local clubs where they can play sports and
they can have friends and where they have something to fucking look forward to
and you will create an infinitely better country.
Infinitely better.
Because our number one problem is people who suck.
And a lot of people who suck,
just need,
needed love.
They needed something,
they needed guidance,
they needed,
and I'm not saying we're supposed to be nanny state in the world,
but I am saying there's a certain amount of people that are born in this country
for sure are going to be fucked.
Why can't we help them?
Well,
if you really wanted to make this world better,
wouldn't that be one of the first things you do?
And in comparison to how much fucking money we spend just blowing shit up in a
bunch of places where we're never going to go.
Yeah.
Compared to that,
the fucking money would be nothing.
There's an article in salon.com which addresses the point you're saying it's
there today.
I believe that says that,
uh,
if instead of the money it costs us to kill bin Laden would have paid for
college and free healthcare for everyone in the country.
God Damn.
It just doesn't seem right.
It's still never seen,
but it's true.
It's just because the,
the military industrial complex has a huge influence on what happens in this
country.
It's what Eisenhower warned about when he left office and that famous speech and
that's just the way it goes,
man.
It is the reality and that reality,
despite wikileaks,
despite anything that gets released about any fucked up thing that happens in
the world,
it's still seems to keep moving in the same.
It doesn't
seem to be any,
any,
any changing.
Yeah,
it definitely doesn't.
I mean,
well you can't change,
I mean their,
their way to change it.
It almost changed.
It almost changed that the summer of love when people were fucking blasted on
psychedelics links,
things were changing.
There was a shift,
man.
There was a real shift happening and everybody got on speed and the ship became
illegal and now we're all like self absorbed lunatics.
You know,
we're all individually only taking care of ourselves.
Our minds are focused 100% on getting to work on time and that's one of the fun
was interesting things to do during rush hour is look around at all the people
in the cars and you'll just see people in a dream sleepwalking.
They're all asleep and that the dream they're living in is that they're the only
person on the planet that's all there is.
Just them,
nothing else.
And we've all trained ourselves to not even look at each other,
to not even say hello,
you want to freak somebody out these days.
All you have to do is go say good morning in Los Angeles.
I don't know man.
Completely different man.
When I went back to Columbus,
Ohio,
it was just like,
hi,
everywhere.
But go to go to go to an airport.
Columbus was super friendly.
I haven't seen there's a,
there's a,
a program thing inside of us that is not,
we're not acknowledging each other at the level that we need to.
And the Internet's changed that to some degree.
It's opened up more lines of dialogue between people,
but one of the ones.
So what I'm saying is the reason this isn't changing is because we're not
changing.
We're,
we're moving more and more into ourselves instead of connecting with people
around us.
And um,
during the 60 psychedelics,
they,
we all know they have an effect that causes a kind of weird connect empathy to
come.
It come into your mind and a weird connection can happen.
Uh,
when you're around people and you feel connected to the whole universe,
you feel like I'm not just me,
I'm a representative of an infinite field of energy.
You know,
and,
and people have forgotten this.
And so because of that,
we're all living life.
Hello learning.
And again,
I think right now more so than any time in my life I hear so I could bug
discussion more than at anytime in my life.
This is a big,
big,
big difference between now and say when I started comedy,
like 1994 people would occasionally joke about doing mushrooms.
Ha,
what is he doing?
Mushrooms,
Huh?
Yeah.
You know,
but no one was like calm and calm with trip reports.
You Know Chris Markus,
our buddy Chris from the flashlight,
he went on a little vacation the other day and was telling me how beautiful it
was.
And you know,
you come back as a,
a better person when you come back as literally like I said this on stage about
the guy who's got those,
those um,
billboards.
It's his May 21st Jesus is coming and I'm like on May 22nd we're going to find
that fuck and we're going to force feed him mushrooms.
I'm like,
because Jesus is coming.
How do you can see Jesus see Jesus and Buddha and Santa Clause.
You can see anything that anyone ever thought of ever plus stuff.
You could have never imagined.
You could see Jesus literally can see Jesus take seven grams,
take seven grams of mushrooms.
You'll see Jesus taught this in the Bible,
that there's going to be many false prophets and that the day will,
no one will ever know the day it's just going to come.
Yeah.
The,
as they said,
women are second class citizens and they can don't slavery.
That's a silly book.
Okay.
You know,
everybody would go crazy about the Bible man,
the,
but it's in the Bible.
I've lived my life by the Bible.
But um,
listen,
here's the bottom line about the Bible.
You're not even reading the Bible stupid.
Well,
you're reading is a version of the Bible that was translated first into Latin
than in the Greek,
the ancient Hebrew version of the Bible.
They don't even know all the words.
They only know a certain percentage of the words in ancient Hebrew.
Like they literally don't know what the words mean.
And part of it's because letters were also numbers in ancient Hebrew,
like the letter a is also the number one.
So like there was a certain numerical value to words that we don't understand
right there.
You're getting the interpretations,
the worst version of the grapevine ever.
And I'm on top of that.
The oldest version of the Bible,
which is the Dead Sea scrolls is so fucking crazy that they don't even use it.
It's just so filled with these vague stories of of trips and you are foes and
visitations and all sorts of nutty shit that doesn't work.
According to John Marco Allegro,
the with the Dead Sea Scrolls is all about,
was them hiding their history of psychedelic mushroom use and they were trying
to hide it from the Romans in stories.
And the older you go back in these stories,
the more you get to the original version of the story and that that's what it
was all about.
These guys were tripping their balls off and it totally makes sense.
Have you were a bunch of idiots.
It was living,
you know,
7,000 years ago or whatever the fuck they were and you know,
you're,
you're living with your stupid leather shoes.
He got all sewn on you and you know you've got some goofy ass hemp clothing on,
you know you're a dope,
you don't know what's going on.
You look at the stars every night and you wonder when the gods are kind of rain
fire from the sky and then you've stumbled across some mushrooms in the end.
You,
you ate them and,
and,
and eight and way too many and had some insane super psychedelic when tunnel
vortex tornado experience where the whole universe is like a giant ball of yarn
and each strand of the ball is like a hyper segmented with billions of planets
and lives and trees and water.
And you can see that for five or six hours and then come back.
You're going to,
you're not going to want the Romans to know about that shit man.
You're going to want to hide all that stuff.
That's what the Bible really is.
What the Bible is,
is a trip report.
Yeah.
That's what the Bible is.
And that's really important man.
And,
and,
and that's the,
that's an important thing for people to know.
And that's the,
I think the,
the,
where things have gone wrong.
Because one cool thing about the people who wrote the Dead Sea Scrolls,
whoever the fuck they were is that they were,
were courageous enough to try to express that experiences that were worried or
reality.
And now when people take a psychedelic,
they mark it off is some kind of dream or an imaginary thing that happened to
that's not real.
So they pretend that this alternate dimension that seems to exist and exactly on
top of ours and is filled with hyper dimensional,
super intelligent beings that throughout time have been called aliens are
angels,
are elves or dwarves or whatever.
The fact that it,
the fact that these people tried to articulate that they tried to bring
something back from that place here.
And just the effect of bringing the,
the,
uh,
close linguistic description of that place onto this planet,
look at the fucking change it caused.
It created a religion.
We date time based on that.
Our current with the way we look at time is after Jesus's birth,
all that stuff.
It's like the,
the power that comes from being able to swim out into the,
uh,
hypersonic waters of the psychedelic experience.
Keep your fucking head about you.
Look at what you're seeing.
Try to understand it in a logical way.
Instead of being like,
I'm Bardian try to understand it.
What is this?
Is this a projection of what's inside of you?
Or are you seeing something that's really there?
And if you're seeing something that's really there,
what are those symbols you're looking at?
What are those?
Is that myon?
Is that Sanskrit?
What is that?
And the more you try to understand that and really get the message,
because there was a message over there,
we've all heard it.
You've heard it,
I've heard it.
The message is the universe loves you and your fine and everything's gonna be
fine.
Don't be scared.
Try to spread love.
Be Positive.
Embrace the world.
Embrace your fucking neighbors and let go of the fear that's ruining your life.
That's the message.
That message gets interpreted in a bunch of different ways.
Buddhism,
Christianity,
whatever.
But it's not like people are supposed to stop bringing that message back.
That's a thing.
People don't want to accept that.
That's where that message comes from.
There's a lot of people,
when you connect something to the idea of it coming from a mushroom or any type
of drug IOWASCA whatever,
it inherently devalues the experience.
Like I,
I didn't listen to it,
but apparently Robin quivers from those Howard Stern show went to Peru and I
heard a lot of talk about it.
But you know,
when I'm in my car,
I never know what episode I'm listening to it.
I didn't catch that one,
you know.
Um,
but apparently she went to Peru to engage in an Iowasca ceremony and they were
giving her a hard time because she's like a Vegan.
They're like,
what?
You won't even drink milk and we'll take this fucking shit.
Which is very funny.
But um,
but you know,
a lot of people will do or poo poo and her experience and um,
that experience,
the Iowasca experienced the mushroom experience.
You know,
everybody,
everybody that is religious wants to believe in God.
What I'm telling you is I can show you something that represents God for sure.
You can meet what God is and I'm not saying it's God your meeting,
but you can meet what God is,
what God is is perfect and all knowing and all embracing and loving and wise and
and constantly around you all the time.
Well when you take mushrooms,
that's what you,
that's what you feel.
You really feel God and are not saying that is God that you're communicating
with or what God is or what,
what are the what even the concept of God when you say God,
all the sudden it says male hierarchy point of you know,
point of reference where you think of like one alpha that controls all but it's
not that God is more like everything
it says.
It's like a super dimensional glob of it's every brilliance and intelligence.
It's this,
it's always,
and also it's,
it's constantly changing.
That's the other thing like it's,
it's like trying to even talk about it.
It's like trying to talk about like a spinning slot machine.
It's like it's constantly like morphing and shifting and it's so fucking potent.
Whatever it is that we're run offs of it.
Like when you see water running down your windshield and like,
streams of water will break into little globs of water.
That's what we are.
We're just a little broken off globs of super intelligence that have taken on
these personalities and think that we're individuals and you know what else
breaks off in that fucking thing?
Elfs hyper dimensional things that aren't necessarily out to love you.
And like there really is like there are beings out there that are um,
I don't know man,
like super intelligent toddlers,
I think mechanic talked about it.
They're like,
they're like baby God or something.
Okay,
here's a,
the devil's advocate point of view,
please.
How do you not know that those thoughts,
those demons just represent thoughts in your mind.
And perhaps what that experience is entirely is you contacting your own thoughts
and ideas and dreams and hopes and expression without the context of reality
attached to them.
So without the idea of,
you know,
what you did that you're embarrassed about,
that made you weird about your underwear when you were 13,
you know,
instead of that maybe it manifests itself in almost a living thing.
It almost,
you know,
that project you're seeing these when you saying you are beings out there that
are fucking with you,
maybe those are things that you've let grow when you're
mind.
Well,
yeah,
I mean I think that that's the modern take on it and I think that that's one
useful handle to like get her get,
get to,
to like grab a hold of an ideal.
I'd be considered
when you were in there,
when you,
you said you had experienced experience.
Like these are projection mechanisms,
the yeah,
that what you're seeing literally is like that thoughts are live there.
They're real things that they look,
you've ever heard the possibility,
I mean the discussion rather of the idea that aliens will come through the mind
and that they're not going to manifest themselves in a real form in that when
you think of the imagination and when you think of dreams and what we have is
some weird,
slippery sort of experience that we can't completely control.
But what if that dimension of dreams,
that sleep dimension that you tap into and all your neurochemistry starts
flowing between the blood brain barrier.
While you're in heavy rem sleep,
what does that is in fact another dimension.
What of that is in fact a world and that is where aliens will contact through.
They will contact you through this spiritual dimension instead of a physical
dimension.
Yeah.
Well,
if that's the case,
and if you think about taking mushrooms and these these l show up,
it is possible that negative things that you've created in your own life,
shitty choices or bad energy that you've set forth and then nurtured and and
repressed and put it down and tried to deny it and all of these different things
that people do to sort of rationalize creepy things that they're doing in their
lives.
What if those things manifest themselves as living organisms in the free pool of
your mind?
Yeah.
You know,
that's actually,
I think fucking Carl Young said that exact same,
I met Carl Young this weekend.
Maybe he's a man,
a crazy guy who took ship 6.8 grams of mushrooms and told me he was crying.
Yeah.
This guy comes up to me and he goes,
he goes,
I need to talk to you.
I have information that I'm sure you don't know about.
I go,
how can you be sure?
And he goes,
I just know.
I just know I tried to talk to Brian Red band about it,
but he replied to my email with some stupid joke.
I go,
that sounds like Brian.
I want to give you knuckles for that.
So then,
then hold boy goes,
I really,
I've been doing psychedelic research.
I need to get this information for you.
Listen,
it's going to sound crazy.
I used to be in another life.
I was Carl Young.
I go,
how can you be sure?
And he goes,
I've seen things that you've never seen.
I go,
how can you know that this is ridiculous so you get to confidence on get out of
here.
And I kicked him out of there.
Right?
That guy I was,
do you remember?
Yeah.
I got to find that email.
That's crazy.
I talked about him on the podcast,
on the plane with Sam.
Triple a did,
but that podcast might suck.
I'm not even going to release it.
I might not release it because we were both hung over and tired and we're
talking about stupid shit.
So I'm not sure if he's still a little
hung over from fucking Joey Dhea is giving me a banana cake.
Yeah.
I got a text from Brian in capital letters do not eat.
Joey Diaz is banana bread.
You can never eat edible marijuana.
That Joey Diaz,
given that as you have thorazine on hand,
don't take that.
So let's see.
You have a fucking big hydro German filled with adrenaline that you could stuff
into your chest up.
Oh Dude.
Joey Diaz gave me,
uh,
you,
um,
once gave me like some breath strips I guess is the first time I take in breath
strips and he was like,
eat two of these.
And I'm like,
no.
He really tell you,
hey,
I don't tell anybody ever detect more than a quarter.
I hold their hand,
I go,
dude,
listen to me Bro.
Listen to me.
I love you.
Don't take more than a quarter.
Joey likes the,
towards knowing Joey Diaz.
That's what I did.
I only took half of one of these knowing him and I was driving home on the
interstate and I was like,
well,
it's,
it's definitely the apocalypse world is ending.
I see that clearly now I'm in the last days and uh,
and um,
there was a McDonald's and I was going to stop my car and run to the Mcdonald's
ticket,
a burger because traffic wasn't moving.
That's how bad the logic was working in my mind.
Uh,
just get them fucking,
I know I can make it there to get a diet coke and back.
But anyway,
I get home,
I'm having the most terrible marijuana trip.
I'm laying in bed.
I'm like,
oh my God,
the world's in my heart's pounding phone rings,
phone rings,
Joey Diaz,
I answered.
He's like,
welcome to my house,
motherfucker.
[inaudible]
he thought you took all two of them so he knew the no go into recording.
Yeah.
I suppose you just surmise that it's so crazy.
You have his buddies.
I got the Listerine's the asset thing and there was like a few of them in there
and I guess they all melted together.
Do you remember that?
I did that.
I did that one guy took like a bunch of them ever did.
He never smoked weed.
He never ate wheat and he was like his first time trying it.
So Joey,
you know,
gave him some entity.
There was like a lot in there and they had melted together into one and got a
massive panic attack.
I think the guy called him the ambulance get called by one one.
He had a panic attack.
Yeah,
we'd see.
That's the thing man,
there needs to be a special now I want one like when you press a button on your
phone when you get directed,
like have you eaten edible marijuana press was Cherry Garcia someone he can calm
me down.
Yeah,
it's just music.
Well what people don't realize is that there's cannabinoid receptors in your
mind that are established for two things that come out during like runner's high
and you're,
you know,
and some other things.
But also they're there to like to receive marijuana.
They're the receive to receive all the shit that's in marijuana.
Marijuana easily could be responsible for human behavioral development.
Could easily,
we could have a long time ago,
I've had some sort of a symbiotic relationship with marijuana.
I mean you look at the characteristics that it's all about like being loving.
It makes people kinder and friendlier and Sillier and less threatening and more
insecure.
So it makes you like less cocky,
you know?
It's all like good things for society,
you know,
and they,
human use of it has gone.
I was at this,
Oh God,
I've got to tell you about this.
I know the history of cannabis because I was at a place in Toronto.
They had,
I went to this nutty fucking place.
It is Valhalla for pothead comedians.
It's a head shop and in the back room they have a comedy club.
Cool Dude.
It's called Clint.
I probably shouldn't say what it's called.
I think it's on the DL.
But anyway,
you go there and they had this big thing,
the history of cannabis for 4,000 years old evidence of cannabis use in China.
And it goes like throughout human history,
how long people have been using marijuana and they're selling bongs or sell them
like pipes and shit.
And then you'd go into the back room and they have a comedy club.
That's cool.
They have a comedy club dude,
and you go on stage and everyone,
I went onstage and sparked up a joint and immediately when I got it,
it's a full hot box.
You can't see the back of it.
It's filled with weed smoke.
And the whole time I was on stage I did like an hour.
The whole time I'm up there,
dudes are hitting a bong and they're,
they're passing joints and it's fucking crazy.
Too much.
Like,
too much,
too much my voice.
Well that's one of the reasons why I'm coughing today.
I think I'm just breathing in that.
Yeah,
that's Sam.
Sam totally lost his voice almost.
He's like,
yeah,
that motherfucker needs ventilation for sure.
But my voice was like really hot and red,
but it didn't affect me the next night when I did the UFC,
it didn't bother me at all,
but it was hot and,
and like I remember getting out of there going,
God,
I got to go outside and breathe.
And then the cool air of,
I mean literally there was no oxygen in the room,
it was just pot smoke.
It was fucking crazy.
And the way Toronto is right now,
apparently there's some sort of a situation where they had a law to make it
illegal,
but the law was ruled unconstitutional.
So that in the 90 days between the,
the next revision of the law,
it's basically in limbo.
So it's like flea on pot,
sort of legal,
sort of,
you know what I mean?
Like they could probably bust your balls if they wanted to and lock you up and
they would,
you'd,
you know,
who knows dude?
Yeah.
Did they,
at the history of marijuana a thing,
did they talk about the white mommies and China?
What does that,
no,
in fucking China,
they found these white mommies that are Caucasian mommies.
Oh,
you know about that?
They had like blonde hair and they had fucking weed on it.
Yes.
And they were like tall.
Yeah.
Tall Caucasian mommy's,
yeah.
With marijuana.
And we,
yeah,
we use that data to,
um,
I was like,
I don't,
I don't know.
I'll fuck it up.
I said [inaudible] thousand years.
It was long,
long time ago.
But the funny thing is on the Internet,
you can look it up.
There's a national geographic thing about these mummies and there's a scientist,
uh,
being like,
um,
I don't like saying this,
but there was marijuana on those
mommies.
Like it's a four years.
I don't like saying that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
How could people,
why are people so reluctant to admit the positive affects that all these debt or
the effects,
the,
the need that people have for all these different intoxicants?
Why is it mean,
why is it so mainstream to dismiss it?
Is that some Nancy Reagan Shit,
the stove left?
Yeah.
Well I think it's older than that.
I mean,
God,
we kept like,
isn't it like the people who came over here for in the beginning were super
religious and they had all these like ideas about sex and uh,
Eh,
uh,
intoxication that were really super strict and we're their distant ancestors.
And somehow that line of guilt still remains.
Where if people,
like I only drink after 5:00 PM I'll only smoke marijuana after four 20 you
know,
they said all these things because like you can't,
you're not supposed to be in an intoxicated state more than a little bit.
And if you are,
and then you've got a drug problem,
I must have a drug problem when it's,
isn't it?
Isn't it possible that not all drugs are exactly the same?
You know,
isn't it possible that you don't put everything under the umbrella of drugs?
Yeah.
So
what's holding you back?
Do you think it,
the people that are holding it back,
I've always said no one needs pot more than the guy who wants pot to be illegal
right now.
No one needs acid more than the guy who wants to make acid delete.
Sure.
No one needs mush,
you know,
down the line.
It's so simple.
So how is it still in a situation the way it is in today,
in 2011 with all the information that we have,
it's still never get stopped.
And there's a feeling of helplessness.
Well,
you
know,
they have reopened tests into a Mtma and Psilocybin,
uh,
the Multidisciplinary Association of Psychedelic Studies.
You can go to their website.
Um,
they're,
they,
they've got federal,
they're doing federally approved testing with Mtma for people with posttraumatic
stress disorder,
which I think is a great thing.
You know what I mean?
And I think it's going to be extremely beneficial,
especially Mtma,
you know,
there's a lot of really positive results with that.
You know,
I think a silicide me gets a little squirrely,
you know,
if you've had some horrific experiences abroad,
I wouldn't recommend silicide been,
if someone asked me was the drug of choice,
I wouldn't answer.
So they're not using that to treat post traumatic stress disorder there,
especially if you might've done something,
you know,
not really entirely happy about,
what they're using it for,
what terminal illness.
Those are the experiments that they've been doing,
uh,
where they,
um,
give silicide and to people who have late stage cancer and it helps them
overcome death related anxiety because you take it,
you take synthetic silicide in which I would love to try,
which is a,
I'm so much better than apparently regular.
Actually.
I think that you're supposed to say psilocybin,
but uh,
because it,
um,
it's easier to dose out.
You know,
when you're eating mushrooms,
it's not like each mushroom has an exact,
a certain amount of psilocybin at one of the trip is his name.
I don't know.
I bet the speculation about a psychedelic trips is that the more people take the
psychedelic trip,
the more potent the psychedelic is.
So like those,
the thing with ketamine that Mckenna always talked about how ketamine some
seemed like nobody had been there yet.
Like you did this psychedelic experience and you got there,
he said,
describe it as like a giant office building,
but all the cubicles are empty.
You know what I mean?
Whereas like mushrooms,
right,
my space,
2011.
Whereas mushrooms,
it's like you are diving into a giant rich river of human history and it's all
together,
all in one gigantic fucking soup and you're going to add your trip to this huge
pool of trips.
So,
you know,
the way they're doing these tests,
is uh,
so fucking cool.
And now it's so loved it,
uh,
have this,
they have people lay down on a bed and they have sitting on either side of them,
psychotherapists.
So while you're going into the ecstasy experience or while you're going into the
mushroom experience,
you have these people who are there to talk to you so that when you say,
man,
there's fucking super intelligent toddlers swimming through my body and mocking
my thoughts,
they could say,
oh,
let's talk about that.
What,
um,
you know,
what do you think those things are when you see them?
Describe them to me.
Or if you don't want to talk,
they don't.
If you don't,
if you just want to be by yourself,
they leave you alone.
But they guide you through the experience.
Like,
it's kind of like Western shamanism,
but,
but have they have the experience themselves or are they just sort of a neutered
bystander?
Um,
you know,
I think if they've had,
have had the experience,
I don't think that they're going to announce that right.
Because it's such a strict fucking thing and just the fact that they're letting
them reopen tests since,
uh,
I believe October six,
1966 was when Lsd was made completely federally illegal and all testing on
psychedelics was brought to a halt,
bringing us into a kind of pharmacological dark age where nobody could fucking,
uh,
even experiment with the substances that are,
I know what it is.
Meanwhile,
you know,
you could get stricken on and pull it out of a plant and no one's ever going to
bat an eye.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
you have people getting cat scans and their fucking brain looks like the surface
of the moon because there've been slurping back shitty club ecstasy and God
knows what the fuck that is.
You know,
they haven't been taking like pure pharmaceutical grade chemicals,
which is what you should own.
You should only take that when you're taking a hallucinogen.
Do you think that this,
this,
uh,
idea of a trip,
like when you take mushrooms that you are entering into accumulation of trips
throughout human history,
does that make sense to you?
And if that does make sense then is this the silicide than that's chemically
produced or that's artificially produced?
Does that bring it to the same place?
Yeah,
I bet it does.
And I,
it's just a radio frequency wand tunes you in two different ways may be slightly
different,
but it's like you're still tuning into the same fucking station.
And I been also,
you know,
the,
the different tests that they did.
Um,
for example,
the Good Friday experiment at Harvard where they gave Psilocybin to people in
the basement of a church and pipe down the church music to see if it induced
mystical states and the modern stuff Johns Hopkins is doing with the same exact
purpose to see if you can create mystical experience.
The effects they're having,
they had from that is like people from the Johns Hopkins experience are
reporting a year later that their lives are better,
they're more connected with their family,
they feel like life is more worth living,
their anxieties decreased.
There's really positive results from it.
Wow.
A lot of it's probably like,
you know,
when you,
you're in your DNA like yeah,
I have my grandfather's nose and stuff like that.
Like the history of your own DNA.
So like maybe mushrooms lets you kind of tap the history of your DNA some way.
Like a Maybelline.
It's probably,
yeah,
it's probably information,
you know,
I mean,
what,
when you look at instincts,
like a lot of instincts are set up just to protect you,
you know,
from,
from shit that's happened to people in the past and it's become,
you know,
a part of the human instinct,
like a category,
the or catalog rather than you have in your mind.
Oh yeah.
She'll like the reason why people are afraid of monsters.
You know,
little kids that grow up in cities are scared of monsters.
Well,
the reason why is because you know you were a monkey's jaguars used to eat
people.
That's why you're scared to go out at night.
Why are you scared to go out at night?
Because the predators were fucking hunting you at night,
man,
you got eaten.
When they look at like a lot of the early hominid skulls,
a lot of them show signs of predation by big cats.
That's what we're scared of.
So that,
that monster,
that flash in a child's mind,
a big teeth and it's scary beast.
That shit's ingrained in the memory.
There's,
there's something in there from one monkey a billion years ago or whatever that
saw another monkey get jacked by a cat,
you know?
Well and also that's why dogs are so excited when you come home because like
back when people first started domesticating dogs,
if you went out on a hunting trip,
I,
there's like a good chance you were just going to get killed.
Like coming home used to be a much bigger deal.
That's why you're,
you survived.
Cause the dog's still tuned while,
I mean Shit,
if my dog goes outside,
it's still Mike.
At Eaton.
I'm a little Chihuahua.
You know,
I think one of the hardest things for us to really wrap our heads around is that
we are just one frame and this infinite chapter and we're all trying to figure
it out as it's going along.
We're all like trying to lowball stop this ride slow down.
Let me get a map of this.
Let me hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Who is running the train?
Do we know who's running the trends?
Can we slow the train down?
Shit.
I hop off the train and watch it from the outside.
They'll let me stay on a little longer.
Where are we going?
What time is it?
Does anyone have the time?
We are all on this wild train ride and it's going to become someone else's train
ride next life and it's going to keep going.
You don't.
We were living and dying on this ride for as long as it takes.
Actually the person on the train ride isn't you.
It's your DNA and that's why it's always trying to get you to fuck is it knows
you're the train.
It's on.
It's going off the tracks because you're going to die.
It's like you gotta fuck.
You got to make more.
I got to get off this thing.
Eventually.
You're not going to last.
You're not going.
No Way.
Eventually,
yeah,
you're were all warm food,
man.
There's no question about that.
Don't entertain the idea.
If you think you're not fucking dirt,
then you're out of your mind like we're all doomed.
There's no way out of it.
We're all getting sucked into the future where we used to it.
Your bodies,
this body that you're rocking right now is not going to last our body.
Yeah,
I mean what we really are.
that's right.
Who knows if does that true though?
Everybody says,
yeah,
I know,
but you don't know.
You don't know any more than you know that it does.
It does.
It's a fucking giant guessing game.
Well,
you know,
it's one of the most offensive things about religion is that they pretend that
they know something that is impossible to fucking know.
Well,
that's just as just as ridiculous.
When hippies pretend that when they die,
you will go into this interdimensional love.
You don't know.
Can I,
can I,
can I be,
can I please be the obnoxious hippie?
Sure.
Thinking take that,
uh,
be at the hippies advocate there and say that,
let me be at peace advocate.
The,
um,
the,
uh,
I,
I think that,
you know,
the idea that people maybe have that you retain your personality when your body
stops existing and you go into some kind of like new age,
um,
uh,
paradise where you're flying around sipping honey out of the craters of heaven.
And after you're there for a certain amount of time,
you're like,
you know what?
I think I want to go back to earth and reincarnate as a kid with down syndrome.
I don't think that,
you know what I mean?
I don't think that that really happens because I don't believe that,
um,
so many people on the earth who may be your,
are born like with disabilities are an incredibly difficult situations.
It's hard for me to imagine someone at a super dimensional spa,
um,
being like,
yeah,
you know,
I want to,
I think it's time for me to reincarnate as a blind person who,
um,
can't walk and to,
yeah,
I know,
you know what I'm saying?
So that's silly,
but I'm,
and sorry for the two long explanation for that,
but,
um,
but I think that there is a nother thing that we are,
no matter what,
which is our consciousness.
And I think once the body ceases to exist,
that consciousness continues to radiate inside of everything,
in through everything.
And that's what we really are.
So
I'm not necessarily convinced,
I'm not necessarily convinced that consciousness is not attached completely to
being a biological entity.
Then you know,
that one of the things about being a biological entity,
being some something with some sort of,
uh,
you know,
you have personal sovereignty,
you have the ability to control your own movement and destiny.
That's why consciousness like the actual thought of consciousness as an entity,
that we're,
that's where it comes from.
It comes from the need to keep this one thing alive.
When you die and you become the next thing.
If there is an x thing,
it's very possible.
There will be no consciousness.
It's very possible that the idea of consciousness system,
egocentric,
ridiculous notion that you have to keep the idea of you when you aren't you,
when you,
you are a drop in a river of information and that's what,
that's what leaves this life and that there is no consciousness.
That's
that,
that idea that you just said,
this is an idea that uh,
is the,
uh,
and you know,
I forgive me,
I mean this an atheist get really mad when you talk about atheism.
Uh,
with some atheist can get very sensitive but atheists are just as silly as
religious.
But atheist have a ghost story.
They really are.
Okay.
Yeah.
Any organization.
But the atheist goes story so,
so Christians have a ghost story.
Yeah.
The Christian goes story is how the atheist goes.
Story is a different Gos story cause an atheist,
well inevitably tell you no,
you don't understand that when you die,
everything stops.
There's nothing complete nothingness.
You can't comprehend it because there's no way to comprehend it because it's
nothing.
And then they stop and they expect you to be like,
oh my God,
that's terrible.
But if you look at what Socrates said,
which you guys should read because it's fucking hilarious and awesome when uh,
he made it what's called his apology because they wanted to execute him and make
him drink hemlock and his response to their attempt to egg or they were going to
execute him,
he said,
okay,
I tell you what,
here's the deal.
If you kill me and I die and there's nothing like when I'm in my deepest sleep
and the deepest,
deepest sleep and there's just nothing at all,
then you've given me paradox.
That's paradise because this isn't exactly the,
a fucking fun park here in early Athens.
And guess what,
being in complete nonexistence for infinity might be better than not having to
like sneak around and fuck 14 year olds cause I'm getting too old.
The catch him.
I think I gave you catch these 14 year old a Olympian athletes,
but,
and then the other thing he said to them is,
if there is something after this,
if I die,
if you give me this stuff in there,
some other thing and I continue to exist,
then I'm going to keep doing what I was doing here,
which was going around and embarrassing everybody with is a motive inquisition
that essentially makes you realize that you don't know anything.
Well,
have you ever heard the theory that every timeline,
every life is,
is repeated until you get it right?
And that what we're dealing with this one timeline of,
of this earth that you are listening to this podcast right now,
you are a part of an infinite number of timelines that are all interwoven and
that you go through this one and then you come back until you get it right and
you keep doing it until you have no shitty thoughts until you have nothing
wrong.
No personality defect until you literally,
literally,
ultimately achieve enlightenment.
Oh,
can I add,
can I add something?
Biggest hippie theory.
Let me,
I mean,
you say it is,
but not evidence.
The evidence states that the universe itself is fractal.
Okay.
And the latest findings about big bang or about a black holes rather,
is that inside every black hole that exist,
the possibility of another universe.
That's the ultimate fractal because we know that inside every is a black hole.
And if inside every galaxy there's a supermassive black hole,
that's exactly one half of 1% of the mass,
the galaxy.
And what the theory is,
is that inside that black hole exists a whole nother universe with hundreds of
billions of galaxies,
each with a black hole in the center of them.
Each has hundreds of billions of galaxies inside of it,
and it never ends.
And it literally is the ultimate fractal.
If that's the case,
I don't think it's that preposterous that your silly little fucking life can be
repeated over and over again.
You know?
Oh,
I'm going to be Bob the post man til I die.
No,
no,
no.
You're going to be a Bob the post man for infinity.
You motherfucker until you get it right.
I don't think that's any more ridiculous than the idea that inside every black
holes into their fucking universe.
I think that's positive part that that's kind of ridiculous and until you're
positive and you have no negative energy,
that just sounds like [inaudible] you can live your life without,
without fucking it up.
But there's a negative that's positive.
There's a negative version of that idea that you just had and it's from
Nietzsche and that his idea is exactly the same thing.
It's called infinite return or something.
The law of infinite or I can't read the name of it,
but his idea isn't that when you get things right then you get to move on his
ideas.
No,
you don't get to get things right.
Everything just happens infinitely.
Exactly way it happened this time.
So the amount of time in your life,
if you are happy or more than you are sat in your life,
then you are in heaven.
And if you are in misery more than you're happy,
your life in your own hell,
and that goes on forever and a day job.
That seems like a giant leap though.
If you,
you can live this life over again.
You're telling me that somehow or another,
what kind of super order can have every car stop in the exact same spot.
Every red light be there when you get there.
Every wind your DVD.
Yeah.
Okay,
so life is just a movie.
Sure.
Everything that's ever been done in your life is predetermined.
Maybe there's this,
these are all thought experiments.
By the way.
I Nietzsche was using it more as a true experiment then I,
all I'm saying is that it just requires this giant leap to think that
everything's going to fall into place.
Exactly.
Well,
it all goes back to the idea that you are,
you are the only person that you can prove has self awareness.
Right?
You don't know that eyes have self awareness.
You don't know that Brian has self awareness.
You can't you.
Yeah.
So that's the idea.
So you can't prove any anybody.
There's anyone else except you.
Right?
You like to think that we all have self awareness.
You like to think that we're not projections of you,
but it's,
it's possible that you're the universe in the very first phase of it's waking up
and as it's,
and it's having this nervous breakdown where it projects this bizarre reality
where you're like hosting a podcast and you host the UFC and you,
um,
you are,
uh,
you used to host fear factor.
I mean,
it doesn't at all seem kind of absurd,
like a ridiculous,
weird dream.
Do you really think it's happening?
Well,
that's the idea.
If you,
if everyone can individually do that same thing to them and look at your life
and really think of all the coincidences and synchronicities that have happened
in your life and all the,
all the bizarre events that maybe have even just happened today,
you really think that that's all an accident.
You really think that this whole thing hasn't been planned out just for you
anyway.
It's a narcissistic idea.
Yeah.
But it is a narcissistic idea and really,
ultimately it's just one of a million different possibilities.
Sure,
sure.
And so to commit to any one of them.
It's just like the idea of you saying the atheist.
I feel like this is it,
man.
When it's over,
it's just darkness and emptiness.
Woo.
Whoa.
The other,
the other atheist Boogie man is the guy who shoots people at the abortion
clinic.
That's the other one.
Oh yeah.
That guy,
no shit.
Terrified of that guy.
But meanwhile,
they're not terrified of a vacuum cleaner sucking babies out of pussy all day to
shooting babies into the great beyond out of a vacuum cleaner.
Yeah.
That specific spot every day.
That's your job.
What?
That's a sad job.
Who the fuck is a sad,
you know,
when I was growing up,
I heard bill Cosby for the first time and I was like,
man,
comedy is fucking incredible.
This guy just made it where I can't breathe for like the entire album.
Is there somebody who's like,
mom comes out when she's lying.
Good.
Are you portion when Ri Larry?
Yeah,
and he's like,
oh,
one day I'll give a borsch sons who dreams of being an abortionist.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's something you sort of stumble on,
you know,
fuck this check Craig's list.
No,
if you get her pregnant,
you go,
how did we do this?
You get a medical textbook and I go screen for it.
So this is never happening again.
Learn how to kill baby.
The top shitty jobs,
man.
I mean that's not a satisfying job.
Like if you're someone who delivers babies,
you come home,
you're like,
I delivered three babies today.
Life is beautiful.
What do you do when you come home with an abortion doctor?
So I got no fucking sucked out 30 fetuses today.
I said,
hey babies,
unless you,
you're already some kind of psycho like that,
you know you're one step away from killing people.
So your abortion doctor,
oof God.
Well you know what man,
that takes every kind of people.
I'm sure there's been one of those out there and you know,
if you,
if you can speculate it,
the millions and millions of humans on this and this and this in this country
alone.
Like what if you went to your abortion doctor and he had a dart board or the
fetus on it?
Or if it's favorite TV show is Dexter's estates fetuses,
they're terrible.
I just hate those fucking takes.
They freak me out.
It wore with fetuses.
He's like a fetus that grew out of control.
He turned into a human and just started killing fetuses.
Do you ever toy with the idea that you know mean you said that everything,
you know,
there's this possibility that everything exists by plan and that the same life
will repeat itself over and over and over again.
Do you ever toy with the idea of the human being as as the,
as the Caterpillar that will become the butterfly and that you know,
our whole society,
that the massive accelerating pace is moving us towards this event?
Yeah,
man,
that's the,
to me,
yes.
That's the idea that I adhere to the most.
It's like I don't know what it is,
and of course we can't know what it is,
but just from looking at the weather,
you know it's gonna rain and you can look at what's happening now and every time
I sit down in front of my fucking Imac and and basking in the glow of world of
Warcraft is I eat edible marijuana.
I considered myself it's only going to be about 20 more years that you're
outside the machine.
They're neurologically gonna figure out how to put you into this place where you
can experience weightlessness,
where the weight of the body's lifted and you can live in a virtual paradise for
the last part of your life.
That's something we all have to look forward to is making the decision.
I mean,
depending on how old you are right now or how healthy you are,
you will eventually have to make the decision between spending.
Most of your time in this world are spending most of your time in a virtual
universe.
A,
a virtual paradise that is indistinguishable are probably only the
distinguishment is that it's a million times better than here.
And then somebody will hack it because it's made by Sony inside your head.
Yeah,
sure.
Fucked.
Oh No.
All that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
There's gonna be,
there's gonna be some problems initially,
but isn't that crazy about that Sony Shit?
I mean,
yeah.
What exactly did happen first?
Like their,
their network just went down for a couple of days
and,
right.
But they didn't say anything and supposedly a hacker got in and they don't know
what they got.
Like they don't know if they got their names and credit cards,
but they,
there people are thinking,
I got like credit card numbers.
That's like millions of people's cards.
Are they?
I told you I got jacked.
Yeah,
they stole my credit card.
I started that.
I get phone calls from American Express.
Are you buying $500 worth of Godiva chocolate?
I guess they probably bought a bunch of gift cards.
Gift cards.
Yeah.
And you can,
you know,
did you go to Norman in Nordstrom's and you know,
spend $2,000 in Neiman Marcus?
Did they just went off these fucking people?
Yeah.
That sucks man.
Yeah,
it's creepy and it's weird to know that this is weird little electronic
parasites that click,
click,
they get the number and then,
you know,
they make a new card and they just sucking number
present website just got infiltrated by [inaudible] and they went into the html.
I still have to fix it.
If you go to my website now,
there's nothing there.
I didn't take it down,
but um,
they went into the,
they injected into the html of my,
uh,
index page and say any place there was html,
some kind of fucking I frame that took people to a website in Russia or
something.
So when you went to my website,
a Google alert would pop up and say,
this side is known for hosting malware.
Wow.
And I did go in and like erase everything,
but they got my password,
which is totally weird,
man.
It's like,
I don't know how they figured out my fucking password.
I love documentaries
on hackers.
There's this documentary they did about this one area of Soviet bloc,
Eastern Europe.
I forget what exact country it is,
but one,
one Soviet country,
one former Soviet country,
and they're all hackers,
like the whole country fill the backers like they went through this city,
like everyone's got a Mercedes.
They just fucking everybody,
they just figured these young guys of like figured out a way to fuck the system
and steal all this money.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what that happened.
It sucks.
What is that?
How do they do that?
I have no idea.
That'd be fixed.
It's a Bot.
It's a Bot makes down with it.
Obviously a shitty password or maybe they,
um,
I got my fucking a world of Warcraft account act a while ago.
Really?
I'll often do you play that fucking matter?
I love it.
My gas rack is a warlock and he's almost level 71
feel about the guys who buy and and sell their,
their characters.
When you think about that,
is that cheating?
Buying a character?
Yeah.
Like if you can't,
you like build up some sort of characters.
Mine gold.
Yeah.
Can't you do something like that where you get your characters?
Yeah,
you can do that,
but you're going to miss the friendship and companionship of your guilt.
Don't you want to,
there's lifelong friendships we formed.
You have buddies and your guilt breaks.
Wrote a Warcraft is like every couple of months he'll break it just so you won't
play it.
No,
I don't break it.
That doesn't work anymore.
Blizzard fix that now you can like it's there no matter what.
Like yeah,
he's an online is.
Yeah,
cause I get obsessive with video games so when I get addicted what I do is I
just delete,
destroyed the property,
make it so that I can't play it anymore so that it hurts.
There's a roadblock in between me having to download it and then inevitably like
I'll download it again and play.
It's a cycle of addiction.
Him that in starcraft,
you're on both of them now.
Do you have to have it inside your computer?
Do you have to have a CD in there to play it or does it an online store you
download the beautiful,
beautiful thing you don't need to,
but you have to have it on your computer.
Cause like quake live,
you download like a client app.
Yeah.
But it's all online now.
Well I don't know how much of it's online is just like,
it's like eight gigs.
Yeah.
But that whatever's,
there's a,
obviously there's obvious other servers that are,
but what do you get to do that so cool that you're on it every day.
Do you get to shoot people or what do you do?
Kids make believe?
I wish that town wasn't in your voice when you're asked that question.
Are All different?
I have no,
it's a,
it's a up my video game.
Murders,
tendencies.
Listen,
it's embarrassing and uh,
it's,
it's childish.
I'll totally admit that and,
but it's fucking awesome.
Like they figured out a way,
cause you know,
we've got the human beings are based on a reward system.
You do something good and you get our award and that makes you feel good.
You go jogging the endorphins kick in.
Whenever you accomplish a task,
you feel good.
So the people at Blizzard and the CIA join forces and they figured out how to
neurologically,
uh,
replicate that sort of endorphin rush and it kind of ever accelerating pace.
So the game,
the higher level you get,
the more the game begins to complexify and the terrain that you are used to that
you already thought was cool,
all of a sudden becomes a million times cooler and then a million times cooler
and then a million times cooler so that you get hooked.
Like,
uh,
like pat,
it's like a Pavlovian fucking response.
You just have an online girlfriend,
don't you?
Do you really?
I love her.
I wouldn't call her girlfriend.
What's the odds are that might be a dude.
Um,
it's,
we are who we decide we are.
Joe Doesn't matter.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
that's,
here's,
I mean,
that's a funny idea.
Would you be willing to exchange,
uh,
pretend love messages to a guy playing a woman?
No,
but let me ask you this.
If,
if let's say,
let's say you thought about that for a while.
Let's say,
let's say they call,
let's say in the five,
let's say,
no,
of course not.
But let's say in the future I was rubbing his dick,
but in the future,
let's imagine that this thing I,
we were talking about a neurologically projected universe exists.
People are going to have to deal with super hot girls coming up to them that
are,
you know,
really quite beautiful and you're going to know this prize.
There's chances that guy on earth and the real world.
So at that point,
what do you do?
Well,
it's just a personality.
It's a mind.
The machine.
I've,
I've
dated a lot of girls that had a dude's mind,
you know,
might as well have been a dude.
I mean it wasn't,
but it might as well.
Do you ever
did,
the girl wants to yell at you all the time and argue with you.
Hello?
You are dude,
it's going on here.
Why are you acting all dude like and aggressive?
Why do you have a dip in your mouth but you and grow dips scared that it
now I know that's a big fucking deal breaker right there.
I've got buddies a dip and it never bothers me.
You know spitting in a cup.
It's kind of gross or whatever but when I was dating a chick and she started
doing like the fuck off me,
you crazy bitch.
What's next?
You want to peg a motherfucker?
Oh you want to get your paying on
for those that don't know him Peng is when a girl puts on a dildo and strapped
it on sticks in your but apparently it happens so often.
If there's a name for it
want to fucking weird world.
We live in man.
Weird world.
He at least show some have been Londons did we shot him?
God expre this cycle fucking cheering at the white or the one on the White House
lawn and they're fucking dancing and singing non non non a
lot and they were cheering.
You think we should all be like no.
All right.
He's dead right.
You just calm down.
He was dead in 1992.
I've got the documents right here,
1992 that it's a black ops dude.
I really love that.
That that is a hilarious narrative that Alex Jones is talking about because the
implication is that there's somewhere in the CIA where there's like a frozen Ben
Ladin Ice Cube and they're just awaiting the Melton.
Wasn't that the premise of a movie?
Wasn't there a guy who did that who killed people and frozen and then dropped
the bodies off and,
oh,
I think it was the iceman.
That's who it was.
It wasn't a premise of a movie.
It was that guy that,
uh,
that crazy a hit man for the mom called the iceman,
the iceman chronicles on Hbo.
Which of you haven't seen as,
they are fucking terrifying to know that this guy existed.
He was a crazy fuck.
You know,
that guy used to play pool and he used to gamble.
Not with people that I know,
but that with people that I know who know that people and he,
as long as you didn't make a fool out of him,
he would lose some money.
He liked to gamble,
so you'd go in and play some pool as long as you didn't rob him and make a fool
out of him,
you know,
as long as it was a competitive game.
But I guess he got in some sort of an argument with one guy.
One of the first guys you ever killed was over a pool game.
Uh,
he used to,
um,
and he apparently had one situation with one guy.
It felt like the guy was robbing him.
The Guy fucking disappeared.
Nobody ever saw him again.
He killed so many people,
man,
he killed people over.
Just a guy would step on his toe.
He would kill him.
He would shoot arsenic in his drink and the guy would never know what hit them.
Yeah.
This any in his eye.
He's got that weird accent.
Yeah.
He said,
I had,
what can you do?
Can you do his voice?
It's really,
oh,
I'd have to listen to it.
I can only do accents when I hear them.
Yeah.
He's a strange guy,
but it's,
he stepped on my foot at the theater,
so I just followed him out to his car.
I hope they release this on that def photos though cause they're there.
They haven't decided yet.
Yeah.
Why would they want it ready?
We still got frost on them.
Well I guess a lot of this senators,
he looks like frosty the snowman either 2002 was reported.
He was going through dialysis.
We've got the papers right here.
Yeah,
I don't know man.
I used to have that bit about Osama bin Laden being a character in the Batman
moving.
Yeah.
Just think about this.
He used to work for the good guys,
but Denny switched forces and join the dark side.
He's a billionaire who hates us.
Right?
He lives underground and we almost capture him and every time they get them he
slips away and leaves behind a threatening tape.
I'm like,
this is an episode of fuck it.
Scooby Doo.
I mean this is ridiculous.
And the video,
despite how good video cameras were all over the world was always shit.
Yeah.
It was always like one of those first generation cell phone videos when you can
only take like 30 seconds of video.
You remember those?
Remember that's what the videos have been bin to always look like.
It's always like blurry fucking weird.
He's probably been dead forever,
man.
There was that one fake video that was 100% fake where they,
uh,
they had,
a couple of photos of them in a video of him,
but his face was fat or you're living in a different guy,
like a totally different guy.
Like they put like they put transparencies of the two of them over each other,
but you know,
as they get more sophisticated,
they just stopped releasing videos.
That way she doesn't have to make videos and just have him stop making video.
Sure.
Yeah.
That's the fucking fake bin.
Ladin sucks.
The guy didn't lose enough weight.
Yeah.
So I don't know.
I don't buy it.
It's just they lie about so much shit.
If you don't think they'd killed Bin Lot,
she's dead as fuck.
But I think he's probably dead a long time ago.
I just don't think it just happened.
I mean,
it made,
it might've,
you know,
I mean,
look,
they said seal team six killed them.
And if that is the case,
you know,
those guys aren't going to keep their mouth shut.
They're not going to pretend that they killed somebody.
And I not,
I mean it sounds like,
I don't think they would take us.
I mean,
even when you're dealing with like seals,
there's like a certain,
there's a,
there's a code that those guys live by and I don't necessarily think they would
pretend that they killed somebody.
Like they're supposedly like the baddest motherfuckers in the seals,
the scariest ones that they send into terrible hostile areas to kill bad guys.
You know,
those are the ones that like your reads like some of those books to Dick
Marchenko.
I think that's his name,
the rogue warrior crate fucking books,
all the nutty shit that he did.
Like all throughout the years as a,
as a head of a,
one of those seal team,
six units were there.
They all would like have long hair and tattoos and they would look,
look weird.
It was like a fucking Goddamn Sylvester Stallone movie.
It's like the expendables,
but it was real,
you know?
And,
uh,
yeah,
there's a lot of guys like that man,
fuck,
that's what they do.
That's what they do.
I mean,
if you watch those,
you ever watch any of those discovery channels specials on how they,
uh,
like recruit people and you know what,
you have to go through hell week,
you know,
and you have to go through.
We were not to be a navy seal.
Like,
dude,
the people that get through that or some extraordinary fuckers,
those are,
those are people who would do some crazy shit.
Yeah.
This is a lot of people out there that love and live for the idea of getting a
fucking flat out straight licensed to be a bad mother fucker killing machine.
And if you want to,
if you're good enough at killing people and you're willing to pledge your
loyalty to the United States government,
they'll take in,
they'll take you in and they'll train you.
They'll fucking give you a great attitude.
A lot of psychological,
you know,
counseling that they'd been working on for decades and got it down to a science.
They know exactly how to tune your mind.
So they could send you places to go fuck people up.
2011 baby.
So there's a guy right now from c seal team six.
Yeah,
well there's a whole bunch of them,
but there's one specific,
I was like Kilbane lawn yesterday.
I'd like a cup of,
uh,
I'll take a diet coke and shakes.
I don't think he drinks diet coke.
He's probably drinking whiskey out of a bottle and they're singing.
Yeah,
they've probably been singing since the moment app on the APP and Bandannas over
bullet wounds.
I'll get his perch.
So blurred or boss
fucking animal.
It's fun to think about.
It's fun to think about it being real,
but I'm,
I,
it does seem to me I'm a little suspicious that 2:00 AM they dumped his body off
the side of an aircraft carrier.
The seal team six is the seals of the seals.
That's what it is.
Seal seal team six.
Uh,
it was labeled team six at the time to confuse Soviet intelligence about the
number of seal teams in operation.
At the time,
there were only two others,
but the top team six poached the top operatives from all the other seal units
and train them even more intensely.
So even among proven seals,
the attrition rate for s for team six is half.
So half of the bad motherfuckers that become seals,
the only half of them can survive to be team six.
Oh yeah.
And they sent these psychos over there to kill him.
Wow.
Maybe.
Maybe they did or maybe he's been dead forever.
Who knows?
You know,
who the fuck knows?
It's,
once you hear that Jessica Lynch story,
you go,
okay,
it's all bets are off.
They're not doing anything different now than they were back then.
They were just making shit up back then.
When you said there was a firefight to rescue,
you know,
a private Chesca Lynch and you know,
she was this poor little girl from wherever the fuck she was in Nebraska or
Kansas or some shit,
you know?
And then she came out and she was like,
listen,
nobody rescued me.
I was in a hospital.
There was no gun fight.
You know,
I want to just step away from all this.
Thank you very much.
And then she got death threats and you fucking trade.
Or you know,
she had a Hyde and fucking scary shit,
man.
The government doesn't tell the truth if they're telling us that this happened.
This is not what happened.
Something else happened.
It's a wait,
wait,
wait.
Maybe you don't believe our great President Obama was sitting in a situation
room and being shown the plans to descend on this base.
Osama bin Laden.
You don't believe that that was happening.
Looks good.
Seal team six.
Cool.
I'm going to declare code red.
Some had been like,
yeah,
this is a movie,
Bro.
This is going to be in a movie,
right?
Yeah.
Listen,
Nicholas cage will be any must wait to do this before,
at until after the royal wedding.
I say the cast Nicolas Cage as the hardened veteran who doesn't give a fuck.
And he goes over there because if you're going to do a job right,
got it.
Do it yourself.
It was Hitler's death day.
Remember that movie that he was in with the plane was that movie?
Oh yeah,
it's always on reruns for some reason.
I know exactly.
Get con air is
where all the cons got on.
The plane escaped.
That's the movie,
Bro.
It's kind of the whole cast of Connie or comes back for get Ben Lawn Hitler's
death day.
Who's a top CEO?
Who's his number one killer.
Ready?
Charlie Sheen.
Yeah.
That's great.
One killer Charlie Sheen was in the movie navy seals,
Bro.
Oh,
that's right.
He was in navy seals.
We can make them the top navy seal in hot shots.
Ooh,
there you go dude.
And Major League.
Come on son.
He's all American.
Yeah,
he could be the top of the cop car and Dolph Lundgren makes it come back as
well,
but dies before they complete their mission.
Boy,
here we go.
Let's make it.
You know what your,
your idea is not accessible enough.
Why don't we make it really?
Yeah,
let's make it was pretty mainstream.
Let's make it dads.
Let's make it recently divorced dads,
team dads and they're talking to their daughter on the phone and you know,
daddy loves you.
You want to just like Chloe and bullets into of channel.
Yeah.
And the ex wife,
they wind up getting back together again.
Right at the end of the movie,
Steve Gutenberg,
kids in a navy seal.
You Remember Steve Gutenberg?
I said Alicia Silverstone or playing.
I was like,
who the hell is that?
I don't even remember what happened to them.
Do you have a kid?
What happened to Gutenberg went crazy now.
Yeah,
Gutenberg.
Uh,
there's a famous,
a scene of him outside of Phil Hartman's house after the,
uh,
after the shooting,
after his wife killed him and then killed herself,
Steve Girton,
Gutenberg showed up for the photo op with a suit and tie on and started doing
interviews with the press,
pleading with the,
uh,
the media to have some class and taste and handle this with dignity and to leave
the family alone.
But the way he was doing it,
it was like so clearly him just trying to get attention.
It was the craziest thing I've ever seen with cars.
We,
us as a cast,
never remembered Steve Gutenberg coming up from Phil wasn't like my best bud.
Steve Gutenberg,
we're going fishing this weekend.
You,
I was like Steve Gutenberg's just sort of like,
I'm just gonna neighbor all,
I don't know.
Maybe it's just like a next door neighbor and no,
I don't believe he was man.
And if he was,
why would you come out and say hi,
this is where I would ever come visit.
Yeah,
well it's,
you know,
it's that,
that,
that want to be famous thing,
man.
You know,
I want it goes away.
There's nothing weirder than someone who used to be famous and isn't anymore and
really desperately wants to be again.
Very strange man.
You know,
you ever met a guy that's in a band and the band was big and now they're not big
anymore and they're all weirded out.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
It's a weird fucking symptom and I've seen it on before,
Joe.
It's disgusting.
Navy seal team sealed six team of light used to be famous.
Now he's not.
There's only one way to win back his fame.
Kill the man who tried to destroy America.
Yeah.
That's why I want my movies to have aliens in them.
That's why I liked avatar.
Yeah.
It was simple.
Yeah,
I saw the whole thing common.
yeah,
yeah.
I knew that the guy was going to be good in the end.
I knew it.
However,
it was good cause there was aliens and it was fake.
It wasn't like some stupid real life situation that you're trying to recreate or
you know,
like that's the one thing that drives me the most nuts is people that want you
to go see it.
Really depressing movies,
you know,
really depressing dark movies and you're like,
well I can live that man.
I can see that until I can.
I don't know.
I,
when I go to the movies,
I just want to be entertained.
Now have you seen the fucking speaking depressing movies?
Have you seen the antichrist?
What?
Have you seen the movie,
the antichrist?
No.
What does that Jesus fucking Christ,
I'm just one of the most,
does it pressing dark now?
It's not new,
but it is.
It has some of the most,
well,
I mean it's moderately new.
It's um,
it is so fucked up.
Man is an American movie.
What is it?
It's,
Oh,
here.
I'm looking at it here.
While I've got a lot of stars,
it's really good.
Grieving couple retreats to their cabin in the woods,
hoping to repair their broken hearts and troubled marriage.
But nature takes its course and things go from bad to worse.
Yeah.
That doesn't even 1% describe how fucked up it is.
Oh yeah.
It's really good.
But I mean,
I can't,
I don't want to do any spoiler alerts here,
but there is some fucking does thousand shit that happens and it's 2009 Willem
defoe stars.
Lars van tree or is that his name?
The director.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you're on the ball son.
It just popped into my head.
I don't know.
I usually can't remember my own name.
So,
uh,
this is depressing.
Is it going to be sad?
Yeah.
I mean you're gonna.
It's gonna.
Yeah,
it's depressing and sad and fucked up.
I want,
I'm a monster movie.
Do it.
I don't want that nonsense.
What about the walking dead?
If you seen the walking and watching it?
Yeah.
So good.
It's great.
Fucking love it,
man.
Just got done with the episode one.
I'm gearing up number two tonight.
I'm so pissed that they're not making another until next year.
Why I,
I'm not sure exactly what happened.
I know the guy fired all as writers supposedly at the end of this season.
That's something I heard and yeah,
it's,
but apparently it's based,
it's based on a comic book,
which now I want to read from watching it.
But it's like what's so cool about it man is an other Zombie movies.
They never explore the emotional impact that being in a Zombie apocalypse would
take on you and that what the directing of the acting and that he's really good
at directing people like how to act when they're in shock,
which is what you'd pretty much be in if you are dealing with that kind of like
event happening.
Why is that such a prevalent theme?
The Zombie theme?
Why is that so reoccurring?
I mean at all,
the
potential monsters is like the two big ones are vampires and zombies.
What is that?
It's gotta be some kind of guys,
subconscious,
cultural projection of our realization that we're all kind of wandering through
life like zombies.
You know?
Not really that way.
People are acting as kind of this bizarre,
like they're just thinking about eating.
I mean,
not brains,
but all they're thinking about is like,
I want to have a nice,
you really think that's what it is.
Cause the,
the,
the fear is not just to be a Zombie.
The fear is to get the Zombie to eat.
You.
I think the real fear is people fear,
afraid of cannibalism and people breaking down in d becoming,
you know,
monsters.
Well I mean,
yeah,
I think,
I guess I'm going a little like two,
uh,
two.
I just smoked Joe Rogan's we'd d I think that um,
uh,
yeah,
I mean fuck that is a scary idea is like seeing like,
what's worse than being chomped on by humans that moment when they rip you apart
and put their intestines around their neck.
Why does Aamis always do that?
It's cool.
Looks it looks cool on TV.
Oh Dustin's,
they always have to wear what they wear and they rub their faces in.
It's so gross.
But why did I do that?
Just eat,
just eat.
Stop playing with your food.
What's your all time favorite Zombie movie?
Um,
there's only one answer.
Great answer by the way.
It used to be done at the dead until 28 days later.
Oh yeah.
Just the best one.
20 days later,
Shauna to 28 days.
10 days later.
You know when I loved that they ran at you,
they ran,
I'm not into these slow ass zombies.
He could just pick off with guns.
The evolution of the Zombie there,
the evolution of the Zombie is it's a disease and they run it.
Well that's it.
That's my big problem with zombies is that you're like people in Egypt who had
like regular minds and didn't want to eat brains.
It took them a long time to overthrow the regime there.
You know what I mean?
But somehow zombies are able to overthrow the military and every one of these
movies,
like the military can't stop these shuffling more on,
there's like,
there's like tanks turned over somehow.
Like what exactly do they do?
They turned over the day like,
what do you,
what we need to do is send zombies to Libya to overthrow the government.
Drone attacks aren't working well we,
that's what zombies would do.
They would become a new military weapon.
They would just send a bunch of zombies in an airplane carrier and just let them
lose their shuffle out.
Think you're talking about seal team seven
team like it.
I like it.
Find Osama zombies.
I don't,
what the fuck is that about man?
The Zombie thing.
Zillow.
It's you don't love them too.
People love Zombie movies,
man.
There's a guaranteed core group of humans.
You're going to get every Zombie movie you make.
There's a core audience.
You've got new Zombie movie coming out.
Boom.
You're going to get a certain percentage of people and I'm one of them.
Yeah,
me too.
Fucking love that shit.
I can get me
for every monster movie.
Everything you got bro.
What do you got?
Dragons.
Yeah,
we go there.
You got rules?
Yeah.
Werewolf's there's no way I could avoid it.
It's impossible.
Just check my Wikipedia page.
Somebody says right now.
Yeah,
so when he said that during the twilight series are all [inaudible] to the
wearable.
We've been like saying to people like,
you know,
I'm not saying you know that you should put this on Wikipedia,
but if you do,
I'm not going to change it.
So it says,
it says I'm on some man,
Shit.
It says,
oh,
by the way,
I did Massey Hall in Toronto on Friday night,
2,600 podcast fans.
It was like all podcasts,
except there's one dude who brought his teenage son who apparently didn't read
the signs.
I guess he didn't know what he's getting into.
Like his son probably likes MMA and I'm like,
go see the fear factor guy.
There's signs that say warning,
the Joe Rogan show will contain the strongest language and material content
imaginable.
That's what I came up with.
So that you can't,
you can't say that I didn't warn you.
It says the strongest imaginable and I might be right.
And apparently during the,
um,
there's just one port and my joke where I talk about a fake baby getting his
dick sucked and he didn't like it.
They think he got up in a huff and left.
I heard about some for some people that were in their section I couldn't have
possibly known cause the joke was killing and there was thousands and thousands
of people that Massey Hall is fucking huge.
It's huge.
It's so crazy doing like a show like that where there's that many people.
That's the most I've ever performed for.
And uh,
I'm glad I'm doing that thing lately where I do like an hour and 10 something
like that.
Just the best way to do it,
man.
I did an hour and 10 just,
just stomped it and it was,
I was so amped up for that show.
It was the first show in a long time that I was actually kind of nervous for
like as I was walking,
not nervous like oh I'm scared,
but like,
like all day I was like,
oh I got a big fucking show tonight.
Right.
You know,
and when you go on stage and there's 2,600 people in there screaming and it's
super intimate to the way it's set up.
Like,
cause there's three tiers and they're like pretty much in your face.
They're all in your face.
2,600 of them.
Wow.
Fucking awesome.
And Doug Benson was there and Doug Benson was hanging out with his buddy who's
his opening act and um,
you know,
he was just,
he,
he goes,
I go,
what are you doing tonight?
And he goes,
nothing.
I go,
come down to the show.
So he came down and go,
you want to go on stage?
She goes,
yeah.
So I just,
and I introduced him at the beginning.
We also got Doug Benson,
he and they went fucking crazy.
He goes out and does 10 minutes and just crush it.
Crush,
triple.
He goes up and crushes.
It was insane.
The crowd was so fucking cool.
I mean,
you're always going to get a certain amount of Douche bags.
Like I read a couple things on Twitter about people getting kicked out for
yelling things.
Maybe somebody got kicked out during Sam's,
Zack.
But that's just the virtue of the fact there's 2,600 people.
There's,
you're getting a certain percentage of shitheads UFC weekend and Canadian GSB.
But other than that,
man,
the fucking crowd was amazing.
I mean,
it was incredible.
When I went,
when I was performing with you,
where are we?
Where did we perform at Montreal?
Montreal.
There was a guy,
he wasn't Achler any really.
I mean,
he's an idiot for yelling during your show,
but I really know he didn't mean any harm by it,
but there's a guy in the VacuCap yelling parameds oh yeah,
their meds.
He was just like naming things like he wanted me to do the joke about the
pyramid aliens.
Yeah,
but it went on for the whole show and he was so drunk and it was so important to
him.
They,
he's talked about the pyramids.
He kept looking at his friend with this like really serious,
dramatic look in his face.
Like,
I'm going to get him to do it,
bro.
I know I can get them to do it.
That is the problem with talking about like really heady trippy shit as you get
a certain percentage of people,
like my friend who thought he was Carl Young,
who have to come up to you now to talk to you about things and take what you do
very,
very seriously.
It's like,
you know,
the vast majority of the hardcore Bill Hicks fans are amongst that.
You know what I mean?
That's sure.
The important,
like we were saying is important.
What's going on is important.
How about this?
How about this message you get from time to time?
I thought you should know that I was a fan of your podcast,
but I could not believe that some of the things you said in your last episode we
got,
we get that with my podcast all the time.
That you just lost a listener.
Like,
you know what I mean?
This thing where you're trying to hurt me by saying you're taking your patronage
away from the free content I'm putting up.
It's like,
what are you,
what is the attitude of it's a child's attitude is what it is.
Instead of,
uh,
you know,
having some sort of a discussion or a debate,
I am more than willing to look at someone,
you know,
they say,
send me something and says,
Hey,
you know,
I think you guys are like a little insensitive.
I love the podcast,
but here's where I think you're wrong.
Or I can Twitter,
like someone said that about,
about top gear.
Like I was making fun of a,
all these people for criticizing top gear about their comments about Mexico
until I heard the separate group of comments that everyone was upset about.
I had read some shit that wasn't very offensive at all and to me was a joke.
But then I read and watch the video of the real stuff and I was like,
oh,
okay.
You know,
I'm more than willing to be set hit.
But the guy who did it was very polite and very cool about it.
He didn't,
you know,
oh I guess you're just a jackass and a fucking loser on follow.
You know what is in caps?
It's a child that's a little temper Tantrum,
very stressed out child,
which is fine for me,
man.
When you do something like that,
you don't get a chance to follow me again.
I block you cause I don't want to deal with children.
I don't want to deal with your nonsense.
You want to send me something to try to make my feelings her for no reason like
that.
It's not going to work and I'm going to block you.
It's that simple.
Thank how stressed out you have to be.
Well does he lies into our podcast and be like,
this is the last straw.
And you,
you compose a patch.
Most of them are not even that stressed out there.
You are the target of the day to distract themselves.
Fucked up horde,
horrifying shit.
Hole of a life they're living right.
It's not you.
It's not what you did.
That's so terrible.
And you might look if someone agrees with you or disagrees with you,
it's just a thought and an idea of posing thought and idea to be considered and
accepted or rejected.
It's that simple.
It's like when you get all angry about it and you know that's what you've said
is really fucked up.
Yeah.
And sometimes by the way,
it's great like,
cause I say so many blatantly wrong things like bad,
like bad facts,
like really bad.
It's hard to,
I mean,
and ministers sit right in front of a laptop,
which can do if you want next time I'm thinking of getting you a laptop.
Oh that'd be cool.
So you,
while you're talking,
you have to panic and go with me.
This,
look this up real quick.
Make sure I got this right.
It would save a lot of humiliation man.
Cause like I get,
like I'm saying shit wrong there.
Happens all the time it happened.
It's with,
uh,
with um,
Kaolin Kaolin all the time like fucks up and then has come back.
But look it w w and in that figuring it out and in that,
you know,
and looking up those facts is,
in message boards and discussions,
we all grow.
We all find out.
Like,
like I said,
when I put up the thing about the Photoshop thing about Obama's birth
certificate,
I'm like,
I don't know what's going on.
Somebody tell me what's going on.
You know,
and a lot of people would like,
why would the government do this?
That speculation.
Shut up.
Let's get to the heart of this.
What is going on here?
Photoshop wise?
You know,
it's,
it's so important to have this sort of a back and forth exchange with people
online.
You know,
it's not just throwing something out at,
um,
you know,
the reason why this podcast really works honestly is,
is that it's like people who are tuning into a cool conversation amongst friends
and sometimes they contribute sometimes,
like it's sometimes tweets contribute.
You know,
there's many,
many of discussions.
Many of the discussions that we've had on this podcast are based on things that
someone will send me.
You know,
someone will send me something on Twitter and I go,
dude,
you got to look at this,
check this out.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna read you the story and you know,
and it's this into,
you know,
inner woven network of,
of ideas and people
shit.
That's what it's really all about.
Someone sent me,
um,
something from doing this podcast,
which is the type of music that I'd never listened to called dubstep and a band
called excision.
Have you ever heard of them before?
No.
I keep hearing about dubstep.
Fucking tripping,
man.
It's so weird.
It's really cool.
I don't know if like that makes me an idiot for liking it,
but I really do like it is pull it up,
pull it up.
What does it cause we'll,
we'll,
we'll end and then we'll play this as we're leaving.
Yeah.
Play.
I,
the one I've heard is called swag at it.
You've got to come on this podcast once a month.
This is ridiculous.
I was judging,
I loved schedule you every,
every third week.
Great.
I'll have it done.
I'll put it in my council every third week.
The conversations we have are my most fun.
You're my number one favorite podcast guest on number one.
No one's even close.
There's a few people that are close.
There's a bunch of them.
I love all of them in their own little way.
But you're my favorite.
They can all go fuck themselves.
They want to argue about it.
Ah,
I love all you guys.
Dunkin's number one.
Okay.
Stop it even more than Joey does.
Joey Diaz will get mad at you.
Sometimes stuck in,
never gets mad at you.
Let's say you fucking Momo.
You over there with your fucking don't stop in locked.
Meanwhile,
back at the ranch,
you got some dubstep.
What do you got swag is that song?
All right.
Um,
uh,
upcoming.
We've got,
uh,
I have a show coming up in San Francisco.
I will be at Cobb's comedy club and it looks like I'm doing that with Tripoli
and Thompson girl.
When are we going to do some more dates,
bro?
I know you've been busy.
I haven't been going up,
man.
I gotta I need at least two months of going up every night because I've been
working on your,
your pilot,
right?
Yeah.
Can you tell anybody anything about that?
It's a science show called,
uh,
it's a,
it's a science show for comedy central called,
uh,
well I don't want to go and say that it's just a science show for comedy central
on the pilot was a about the research that they've started doing it and still
it's still assignment and you've been super happy about everything.
We're going to keep everybody up to date about it.
We can't let too much information out.
Very,
it's fucking awesome.
It looks really cool.
I got,
you know,
I got set on fire for it.
Uh,
it,
when will you know whether or not you,
you can actually,
people can watch it.
Um,
I don't know.
Probably June or something like that.
They'll make it as safe.
We'll keep you,
keep you posted.
Everybody who's interested and fall Dunkin on Twitter.
It's Duncan Trussell,
t r,
U S,
s e l.
L.
And you could also get him,
do you have artistic terrorism.com anymore or you've got rid of that?
That's gone.
I haven't,
Duncan Trussell doc got hacked.
Yeah.
Go to Duncan trussell.com and stare into the void.
It's just a black screen.
Yeah.
Catch 'em on Twitter.
Um,
we have shows coming up in San Francisco that is May 12th,
13th and 14th.
Um,
tickets are almost sold out for all the shows.
So a jump on that shit.
And uh,
we should have a good time.
They're my friends.
And then the next Gig I got coming up,
well maybe,
probably sounds comedy hall.
I don't know what's going on there.
They're doing construction.
What's happening?
There's two weeks,
you know,
I looked in the kitchen and there was not one thing different,
in the kitchen.
So 100% the same.
And then June I got um,
June 10th coming up at the vogue theater and that's in,
uh,
oh,
excuse me,
June 9th at the vogue theater and that's in Vancouver.
That's on a Thursday night at the vogue theater in the Vlog is supposed to be
shit.
I can't wait.
And half the tickets were sold out last week.
So by now it's probably like three quarters souls.
If you want to get in,
get in bitches.
I can't bring Joey Diaz to Canada.
I know you all asking,
but it is illegal for Joey to exit and enter into your foreign country.
He's a fucking criminal and you've,
you fuckers in Canada are awesome,
but you won't even allow a Dui.
They have a very strict no douche bag rule in Canada.
You can't have assaults and batteries and all kinds of stupid shit,
not particularly player.
Right.
You know,
I love you bunches and uh,
we will see you.
Uh,
I got stuff to do all week.
So we probably won't see you again until a Friday or Saturday.
That'll be the next one.
Thank you.
Bye Bye.
Bye.
Drove off.
Go on.
Yes.
I got my swagger back.
Just got my swagger back,
not my cup of tea.
How high were you when you die?
This was good and it gets better.
I don't even know if this is the right one.
I'm fine.
Excuse me going,
I have to give it a chance.
There's still 1600 people listening,
dropping rapidly as they realize I've it
down to 1644 41 1636 people are getting violent right now.
Smashing their keyboard.
Bloody knuckles.
I like that sound.
That's what I like making plans right now to kill him.
The lead upset that this weird.
Basically.
I like it.
I like that sound,
but yeah,
it sounds like what would happen if you let a 10 year olds and fuck around with
a computer.
Get into garageband if choice parts
thousands messy are hoping and listen to this.
This is terrible.
Dunkin.
This makes me sad for you as a person.
I knew the moment.
It was just like coming over your house and finding a juice.
Newton poster on your wall
is coming out of my mouth.
He got a fucking
teacher hazard DVD sitting on your coffee table.
This is embarrassing.
You have terrible taste.
Okay.
Goodnight everybody.
Thank you so much.
This is the good part.
What's the good part?
When is the good part coming?
Here's the good person.
The song sucks.
Sucks.
Couldn't suck.
Starting a roast for myself.
I see Jesse.
What's all this piano shit that this isn't it.
This is the part of the song.
That's the part I like
we're making gay people out there right now on this one guy right now.
It's going to just get to,
this is going to be the thing that tosses him over the line.
This crosses line and sends them curling in the gate.
I'm was right there.
He was on the fence.
Flashlights.
Thank you very much for tuning in to the podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen and thank you too.
Fleshlight and if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the
fleshlight and entering the code name Brogan,
you will save 15% off the number one sex toy for men Dunkin.
I have one for you if you'd like to be great and kind of Gotcha.
Gotcha.
New Ones,
new style styles.
Do we hear the good style,
the butthole?
Don't worry.
I wouldn't steer you wrong.
Dog Canned butthole.
Yes,
I have that.
Thank you folks.
Fucking shows over.
Bye Bye.